[Music]
[Music]
you
welcome welcome welcome to the realm
what's going on y'all
a little mic chat going on i might check
my check
waiting for the lords to come through
got a big show and the guests
see what's going on with everybody
what's going on people
i meant she dies a lot you need to
behave
you need to behave sir frodo what's good
jay bailey what's going on talk to me
people
sean sue what's going on hey rodin it's
my man you know what's going on
thank you appreciate it what's going on
just wait for everybody to arrive
what's going on bro oh what's going on
you already know facebook in the
building
you already know grand theft auto i see
you
but holla holland pete what's going on
you see that name hold on pete thank you
for being here in the room appreciate
you
yeah man so we just gonna wait uh we got
a lot of lords waking up attic should be
soon
saul should be soon just gotta make sure
the guests are good we got a big show
planned so it should be fun and uh yeah
man i'm gonna do a little my checking
you know i gotta mute it because the
king
who will be coming through tyler's game
what playstation
you can leave that to king he got that
covered
i was gonna be talking about what else
is going on uh sifu poetic what's up
crazy mate gaming oh appreciate you bro
early y'all here early that's cool 14 in
the chat so yeah we just gonna wait for
everybody
vogel vogue's craig what's going on
yeah we gonna wait for them see what's
up um king will probably roll in any
minute and give us a copyright strike so
you know i gotta mute that
and uh yeah and i think we are streaming
also to periscope on twitter
so i just got to make sure that's good
twitch was good facebook was good
but periscope you guys are new so i want
to see if y'all guys are getting the
realm
live and direct so i'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
exactly exactly all right and we
actually
might check real quick y'all just make
sure everybody chat make sure y'all can
hear
the esteemed guest king just say
something real quick oh
oh make sure you heard that oh and then
i'm starting
uh it looks like it looks good yeah we
go okay and
we are live you totally took the overlay
off by the way oh i did
yeah it's gone oh man i'll mess it up
i'm doing it on the table so how are we
doing we still good yet you're not back
no i don't know i don't know
there we go all right all right i
thought you did it on purpose and then
when you kept going i was like no he
definitely didn't do that
welcome to the iron lord podcast and the
lords of gaming.net
episode number 170 this is another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
don't tell me to wake up jared
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got the iron harvest
open beta
spider-man exclusivity to avengers
samsung and microsoft partnerships and
next-gen launch lineups to discuss
so we're going to get right into it i
want to introduce the lord who is not
only a great friends of the realm but
whose passion for his craft and game
promotion skill set
easily make him one of the most sort out
members of our gaming community
introducing the communication specialist
for koch media slash deep silver
and the pr manager for warhorse studios
our favorite cv slash cd carrier and the
owner
of the most iconic beard and stash combo
in the game live from the czech republic
by
way of germany and making his return
into the realm
of the lord mami lord tobias stole
swelling how are you doing sir
wow thank you very much for these warm
words gentlemen wow
it's getting hot in here man does it go
so fresh off the iron challenge
you showed no mercy well of course
i was invited to kick some ass so i did
exactly
i did exactly that i did i did
everything
people expected me to do so yeah destroy
you
do what you told you to do you know
what's funny i was going back and
watching that
and then uh at like in the middle of
that last game
i didn't know that was you i was
fighting that i snuck up behind and
started attacking and i think myself
why did i pull back
if i would have continued i could have
killed toby right then and then
well it was i told you i was sweating in
the beginning well because you really
did like
a really good infantry push and i was
like really
on the well i was thinking i had to
think about my next moves
but then all of a sudden you were uh
pulling back and then that was
i did pull back i attacked your homies
for some reason i just i went straight
west and i i just left you over there
with with undead
like at the mercy it was a good one
it's on dad's fault man i thought i'm
dead oh come on we're doing it today
we're not doing that today we ain't
doing it
oh my god it's good to have you tomorrow
we got a lot to tell we will get into
that over beta but good to have you
in the realm sir and of course we have a
lord who is no stranger to the realm of
the ilp
but with his high production values and
dedication to his profession
truly helps us understand the
intricacies of virtual legality
introducing the creating host of the
hoglaw youtube channel and the attorney
of the hoglar
business law firm the lord of the
spiciest takes and best legal analysis
and my cherry blossom brother with
ghosts of sushiwa
as his current game of the year
the university of michigan's own
and making his return into the realm of
the lords
my man lord rick hogg how you doing sir
i'm doing okay i think that's the very
first time in the history of the world
that anybody has acute virtual legality
of having high production values
so no i very much appreciate it and i
actually when you said that you were
going to talk about iron harvest i
thought that was a
a good chance for me to come on the iron
lords because i don't know if you know
this but
when i was sponsoring the easy allies
there was a maybe a six month period
where
iron harvest was uh sponsoring the easy
allies right next to me
so i got to see those clips i had jan
from king art uh contact me we had a few
conversations
uh and so i'm i'm eager to hear this
conversation i don't know how much i can
add but i'll definitely be sitting in
the background
that's awesome i think toby smiley
inside look at him right yeah
we're working on it you know it's it's
been amazing and virtually
out i every time i'm on here i say you
know you you had me on when i had 100
subscribers or whatever
and today on this visit we're now i
think 50 away from 20
000. pretty exciting
the grind you know what i was proud to
you is i believe it was our sacred
symbols recently right
i i was proud man i was like look at my
guy he's doing it this is good but it's
good to see your journey man
keep up the good content have you got a
chance to play anything
recently i've been playing avengers beta
this weekend oh nice nice so we will get
into that lot to discuss
there and we gonna move on before we
definitely have locked
before and the time comes for me and
of course last but certainly not least
we have a lord who is quickly ascending
as one of the top writing talents
in the game thought-provoking editorials
and
brutally honest reviews all done with a
high work ethic
and journalistic professionalism
introducing
the creating host of the gaming
perspective podcast and editor for our
very own lordsofgaming.net
the lord of all things baldur's gate and
with a pair of shades
and cap to the back is a dead ringer for
red
succeed blackbeard
live from canada and making his return
into the realm
of the lords my man lord undead 3
x v i how you doing sir i
am so hungover right now i
immediately i i after the uh massive
l we took yes and iron harvest yes i
went i need to go find that 60 ounce or
a gin in my house and nothing's going
away um yeah i know
it's great to be back again always a
great time hanging out with and talking
with you guys
and i'm just going to pretend like i'm
coherent this morning
good gaming perspective podcast last
night i got a chance to tune into the
guys rage
aaron jackson santo but you were you
were very passionate i knew that jin was
in the system
at that rant at the end you went on a
rant about the entire creativity
community
i loved it
i need to not do my podcast and drink
it's just a combination
i mean if if if you repeat that sentence
i would say that that definitely is a
good call
[Laughter]
real quickly uh solve we have some super
that came inside your house
yes we do we have brian falk with the
five dollar super chat i've been
following you guys for a few weeks
a few weeks now love the podcast how did
you guys meet oh wow
uh this is this
we all we all is out the womb at the
same time and um
different bellies at the same time so it
was kind of crazy
when we all came out we we instantly
missed each other
and we found each other on the
playgrounds there you go new york city
there you go
there you go i got a bridge to sell you
yeah yeah basically this brothers man
from from
very very young yes yes um so stitch
with the two dollar super chat
hold up where's my sony baby king
baby there you go
[Laughter]
there we go jay ready five jay ready
five thousand son
with the five dollars head shoulders
knees and toes
knees and toes relax
the full horsemen of gaming those
original laws of the realm here at the
round table
with our updated five-minute intros oh
oh
victor allisteen you want to get that
with the two dollar super chat's sake
and we have an introduction for the chat
oh yeah oh wow we're really breaking
time then
the best chat in the realm yes i salute
you yeah we have to do
a general introduction we could probably
do we could do that what's going on my
co-host with the co-most
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of reviews
and the how of the young wolf my man
lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good now uh obviously some
of you guys know that we took the l
uh yesterday with the you know the iron
harvest as
toby being the main antagonist of them
all uh
you know i i like to say you know what
what i like to say
is that was an addict last night that
was his twin brother
uh he he will not be joining us today
this is attic this isn't this is just
adding this regular addict
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo game who lives for
the single-player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patriarch of
the iron
bank my man lord sovereign how are we
doing sir
what's going on fellas i'm good i'm
chilling out i've whatever i've been
playing lately i've been playing
more ghost of tsushima uh yesterday i
was playing a little bit before i went
to work and i
simultaneously had the stream on
watching my brothers get smoked
man i ain't challenged
yeah it's almost it's almost like they
you know the opponents
made the game it's almost like
i don't know man someone told me that
too but i don't know if that's true or
not
so i was watching that of more ghosts of
tsushima trying to try to motor through
that
yeah um and then carrying man
keep playing carry it i'm at the point
i've evolved that monster to the point
where he has like 10 heads
and he's just like devouring everything
in his path it's so much fun
that's what's up real quick shout out to
brian fork with the four dollar super
chat
king where mario at
um i don't know what oh he was on top of
the box
why is he trying to hide behind that
glass
the fact that i i feel like i feel like
you're going to start filming the next
chucky man
that is spooky i don't like the way that
mario dog move it all right
[Laughter]
that's yeah it looked like he just
stared at king and go
king
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer the lord of combat
sports
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience
and is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing better than you guys from
yesterday
shout out to the iron lords podcast
often duplicated
right but never imitated oh wait wait
wait often
imitated but never duplicate you can't
even say it right
i want them to try to duplicate these
statues why don't you try to duplicate
that part of the iron lord's
uh uh podcast why don't you duplicate
king of the statues trying to go out
there and buy them thousand dollar
statues right paying the tcl bushes
won't belong oh god
wow yo yesterday i was so proud of you
guys uh so toby and you guys getting it
wrong i knew i
had ultimate faith in toby and crushing
damn
i'm
listen just because you cut your time
don't mean you caught other people shout
out to game pass this week um i
downloaded under mine
i've been waiting for dark side is uh
genesis
for the longest so i started my joint in
that
um um my son is playing trail makers
xeno crisis is out of control and the
taurus which is a game that was on the
switch that i passed on
smartly that i got a chance to play that
now and
um what is this other game it was it was
another game that i downloaded that i
didn't get
obviously yes yes yes that's on the pc
yeah yeah yeah
on the beta so definitely uh look
forward to that but
the xeno crisis reminds me of smash tv
okay
wow and i was playing it for a minute
and it gave me that big 16-bit 32-bit
fail
and i'm i'm just like they keep putting
little gems in there that i would have
not
purchased at any point in time and i i
just outright purchased the game because
that's the game that i don't want to be
without so i just outright purchased the
game after i played it so what's up
yourself if you want to get uh
kid hold on one moment uh we got kids
smooth to find out super chat sup iop
afraid i wasn't able to catch uh
this live this week but we all good
heads up to everyone watching make sure
you
ensure everything yeah shout out to kiss
move you know says someone oh sorry
about that i'm sorry i'm sorry he had
just went through a move first i just
saw him last week
because i want to actually pick up his
uh elgato key light that we sold to each
other so he
i bought back from him now but um yeah i
think that's the only time i've ever
seen that someone sells something to
someone and then they buy it back
hold on toby i think you're hitting
twice we got two toys two toby's
what's going on get rid of the old one
yo what's in here but anyway i'll be in
here and perform the shadow clone jutsu
hang on bandwidth can't take it but oh
no but don't real
i'm sorry about that man yeah definitely
about the insurance man i feel you on
that and uh saw if you want to get off
stitch
real quick yeah hold on real quick a lot
of people don't understand that you can
get renters insurance if you rent
it it costs pennies to the dollar make
sure that you get it you probably pay
something like 30
a month to insure your house for up to
three uh 300 000 i think close to that
much
but just just do something like that
against all this time that's going on
now because uh if you do not yet the
mercy of the elements to be honest with
you
it is worth it whatever you think you
you would ever think you're saving by
not doing it
don't think about that and just get it
yeah are we doing insurance sales on
this
a podcast of a lot of our uh uh
contemporaries and
and and friends yeah experienced uh
power outages uh okay sure stuff like
that
yeah and and a couple of my guys they
their basements are flooded and stuff
but they had homeowners insurance
you know so we don't even you know think
about uh
apartment insurance or condo insurance
and stuff like that but you know they
have to
you should yeah you know no doubt you
want to get stitches off uh we have
stitch
with the five dollar super chat hold up
it has been
months and addict has yet to wear his
uniform while king already got his
book man all kings all king had to do is
go to the
go to the task shop and get it i gotta
do it
i gotta wait i gotta wait in this mail
in this whole environment
my eight hours under attack
just go there i gotta wait for this
stuff hey willie hood
put in that comment section how long it
took for you to get your hat
so willy hood how do you think it was
here when i was live wow yeah yeah
yeah it's it's crazy it's crazy listen
shout out to teespring
just under in the bushes teespring like
this
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realness and around the
iop not telling what you want to hear
but what you need to
hear man again shout out to the stream
yesterday it was fantastic we had such a
good time
shout out to king art games shout out to
toby it's so much fun
we you know the results but we learned a
lot
let's just say that but um yeah man
other than that yeah last word was this
friday
shout out to my brother ibantis our beef
is over we made up it's
we're understanding our differences
hilarious
it was a very emotional last word though
the last word prior but this week we
kind of had a middle ground
as far as sun setting and hawk moon
returning so that was good and then
yeah other than that i want to shout out
old the devs from decoy games swim
sanity is out y'all
finally finally out
man you know again two brother team uh
based out of boston right so if you was
the one who brother team along with
their best friend uh
yeah king and i interviewed them two
years ago now at pax east
yeah um and they were just they were so
excited
then we do it again at um play new ny no
at play nyc i know what we've we we
filmed footage of us playing i don't
know if we actually spoke to them again
or maybe we did no we spoke to them off
camera yeah right
but i know we definitely played it at
play nyc if you go to uh
the youtube iron lords podcast you will
see that footage i think we had to get
did we lose the the
the pax footage we might have lost it
the first pack footage we missed we lost
the first pack footage we got the second
pack
footage yeah the sound was messed up
you know a a team of two brothers and
their best friend from childhood just
decided to start making games and they
you know they did everything they needed
to do to train themselves to do that
and it's been a long road because they
expected that game to be out the year
that we interviewed them so this is two
years ago
yeah so obviously it's not an easy thing
to develop a game no matter how small it
is so congratulations to them big up to
them they hit release i think currently
right now
on switch and xbox and pc playstation
nation it is coming to you guys soon
and our very own logicgaming.net will
also be covering that right
right right yeah
it's in my email inbox that i will get
to at some point today
you already know but um yeah that's been
pretty much it and uh still working on
act 2 of goes to see shimon just working
through that getting going
but anyway enough of that look and now
the lords have gotten to what
everybody's been playing
all that good stuff oh nicks off get
[ __ ] i believe we miss
but you know what the fight yeah just
jumped in now being here with the final
super chat
uh i was against series x games being
held back but after my wife's pregnancy
test i'm for the support from phil
maximus pro
consumerists
immediately you realize that your wallet
is going to be considered to be lighter
and you start
when you start wearing your options you
already know that so we got to get
into the show a lot to talk about so
we're gonna oh no toby not here too long
so we gotta get into
our iron harvest man it's out the open
beta
is released and like i said the iron
challenge was yesterday for those who
missed the stream
saturday it was fierce we had our very
own lord attic
undead and lord petey in the realm
you know what i'm saying i told you that
wasn't lord addict
so you know we got to talk about it man
so let's start off with a little toby
again
for those who don't know you know i'm
saying as far as iron harvest
talk to them about the game and then
we'll talk about you know the the stream
of course so tell me
the floor is yours thank you very much
so iron harvest is
uh is a classic rts a real real-time
strategy game
which if you if you think back in in the
90s and early 2000s it was
this was one of the most popular genres
back then i can remember that
i think the first pc game
i convinced my my mother to buy me was
command conquer three tiberian son
because she uh she did there was on the
box there was just this
this sojo this helmet dude and my mom
didn't realize that it's a war game so
she just bought it and at home my dad
who he was able to speak english he then
found out and
of course i was not allowed to play it
so i had this game but
for the longest time i was not allowed
to play it
anyway so uh it's a iron harvest and rts
but
um mechanic-wise it's a lot like company
of heroes so if you if you ever played
company of heroes
it's uh you know it's a squad-based
cover-based combat you cannot just
simply send your troops to the front you
have to pro-manage them a lot you need
to take cover you need to
be careful not to get hit in the back
and so on
and it's a very strategic and and uh the
tactical approaches are pretty pretty
big there and in terms of of setting
it's the
the game is called iron harvest 1920
plus
and this 1920 plus thing is the name of
the universe
so instead of instead it's an
alternative world war one
but instead of tanks they had those
giant mechs
rgs with mechs yeah that's what i
thought i think that's one of the
coolest things about it you know as far
as the maxim
and again the genre now diesel punk
correct
exactly exactly so if you want to if you
think there's cyberpunk coming
soon right so if you think about those
ages first was
steampunk which is somewhat in the
before world war one so in the 1800s or
something
then he has d you have diesel punk which
is in the in the 1900s so world war one
world war two
and then cyberpunk is the future stuff
so those uh
universes are uh linked behind each
other like that
yes very cool very cool stuff but let's
get into the undead because obviously
i'm dead
you were in the mix this is definitely a
genre
he was in the mix
it wasn't a mix and i really blame
attic because adam had the ability to
take down toby
and i know he was like yo let me tag
teammate off and let
and let him get finished and you should
have just finished it
listen always when you got the killing
shot take it
look willie hood he just he's exposed it
all right
attic with a c was playing that game yes
dirty
is here all right attic is the
great naming twin of addicts
but the gaming skills are much different
wow
so you say is that the same addict that
uh played in simple ghosts the other day
that was added with a t she had an
addict with fatigue wants to blame
attic with fatigue's brother it's been
it's been a rough week for
for my co-host you know what i'm saying
we're going to talk about it but
i wanted to before i i'll pass it off to
undead and get off guard
toby i want to shout out will be hunter
can't help you there
i want to shout out games with me again
shout out again i believe it's a lord
elliott and lord will we had the uh get
one of the game designers on the game
exactly and uh the community manager as
well so those guys were great they were
given a tremendous insight
we learned the the the power of the
retreat
functionality
preaching we learned a lot of things
there they were educated
so back to undead man so again after the
experience you know now that you've got
some multiplayer under your belt
what's your thought process on your
harvest well first off
i i just want to throw a little bit of
rocks at addict
and uh because for some reason i was
always the one that had to go against
toby
the entire game in the entire game it
was like okay
petey and actor switching who they're
playing i'm like oh so i'm stuck with
the guy who rushes all the time
by the third game i was like okay i'm
just gonna grab a bunch of infantry and
bum rush the middle and it worked i was
like hey
hey this is working and then he kept
retreating i'm like wait a minute
i don't like this and then the next day
i know i had three giant mechs up me
and uh after re-watching
the the gameplay i i could i
i should have pushed with undead and
took out toby
but see the thing is is in the middle of
the map the other two people were
running loose and i had to go address
them so yeah
yeah but like regardless of what i did
someone was going to die just once
when you have the opportunity and i can
say that from the opposite side from
sitting there watching
at no point in time was my knees on the
line
one thing too toby i wanted to ask you
though in reference to one thing i think
is really cool that's not getting a lot
of credit is the
fact that you guys are doing a single
player campaign a narrative based
campaign and i know solves ears might
perk up there because he is our super
player
experienced guy so tell us a little bit
about you know what you guys got planned
there
and afterwards i want to ask who was
playing the single player
campaign addict and undead you played
them both later
yes i haven't played it yet i'm diving
into that i played it with the the snow
ball fighting thing okay okay yeah
because afterwards i want to ask you
something
anyway so the uh single player campaign
is definitely one of
you know everything started like iron
harvest everything started uh
with the kickstarter right so the boys
and girls from king art games so it's a
germany based studio they went to
kickstarter they said they have this
deal with this
um polish artist who created this
universe and they said
thing or they think back then that an
rps would be a perfect fit for this uh
universe
and they when they did the kickstarter
and even before
they did something like a monster or
like a community shout out
where they try to collect all the um
pros and cons what the people want what
they like on rts is what they miss and
so on
and in the end they came up with
something that they call
and i i would confirm that actually a
compromise
or a combination between company of
heroes from gameplay-wise gameplay-wise
and um warcraft 3 campaign-wise
with the heroes with the with the story
behind with the
cutscenes in between and so on and
actually they have right now
21 missions planned for release
so yeah exactly there's that it's quite
quite a bunch and if you take that one
mission
takes me and i think i'm a somewhat okay
player it takes me
45 minutes in average sometimes more
so every mission you have almost 15
hours of
single-player campaign gameplay for an
rts and then
only gaming without those cutscenes so
you have an hour of cutscene
so there's really really really a lot of
uh uh
content in there for for the single
player campaign and as you know
uh you saw that yesterday there are
three factions in the game
polania something like poland saxony
something like germany and
rusev had something like russia and they
have each
their own uh campaign seven missions
each
but the the plot behind that uh behind
these stories or
well the plot is inter connected um
yeah you you start with the planians you
you finish with the
rules oh so you get a chance to pretty
much uh experience
interaction that's oh that's cool that's
cool exactly and then there's a big plot
with
a huge uh hidden secret in the end uh
coming up yeah yeah
so there's get excited quite quite
quite interesting and and i'd say and we
are teasing and spoiling
and and easter egging this already here
and there so
some people already had an idea about
that and i would like to get them back
okay since you played the single player
campaign
what's your um thought
first is it for you a multiplayer game
or is it a single player
game i think i think it's both really
like the single player caught me at the
beginning
like really good because you know they
they introduced you to this character
and then you know um the whole thing
with the bear and then
you know they really build on she gets a
little older so i had that like little
time jump thing
so uh you know i really enjoyed that but
i guess to me if i
were like a gun to the head what is it
i would probably say a multiplayer
because i i tend to like rts is more for
a multiplayer aspect than a single
player
and that's that's a very good answer
because i um when i think back on the
command conquers and so on and age of
empires and so on the
the single player campaign was always
lacking something
yeah either was it story or a purpose or
whatever
so in age of empires you had the
interesting stories there
in age of empires one and two but it was
always the same thing pretty much
it's just they had a different text in
the beginning and
different predictions but it's always
the same thing and i think
that's what what's so special about iron
how is that the single campaign
single player campaign is really really
big and juicy
however uh when we when we think of
match three
yesterday and the third one where we
were mixed up yes that
that's in my opinion where iron harvest
shines most
when you have the thick multiplayer
match going on
there there are explosions there's a
fighting there you have to
you're sending your troops and
everything is exploding and
i think the multiplayer thing is
whenever i want to wow someone with iron
harvest i'll play
yeah i would say it was very impressive
because the the destructible
environments especially
i love that you just see the pure
carnage on the battlefield and then when
those big
mechs come out it was one that seemed
hogue might appreciate that like what
that seemed inspired by like at
and i was just like i was like i love
the developer's mindset or who is
designing these and the artists you know
say it's just really cool and another
thing i want to shout out like i said on
stream yesterday
the music is really really fantastic
like the great scores some are very
subtle some some are very grim and dark
but
it just has it gives so much to the tone
of the game
so i want to i see petey jumped in the
realm real quick i don't know if he's
muted
but uh if peter if you could um we get
your um takes on it man this man is
in the realm and the east coast is out
of power this man is gerrymandering off
of power
right now just don't worry i i apologize
quickly just let me get these super
chats
please please get the super chat they
will get the pd buffer you can hear me
right i'm good um so we have philly
eagle with the 5
super chat good afternoon lords good
afternoon gamers hope everyone is well
thank you sir thank you sir then we have
g man with the 5 super chat addict and
ghost
gears rematch on pay-per-view would be
epic
i i i'd rather throw my
eyebrows out before i play gear watch
your sponsorship
pull my eyebrows up before i play the
multiplayer gears
wow okay then we have stitch with the
two dollar super chat king can you let
addict borrow mario's hat
please oh my god you're slandering my
co-host
yo the question is um did we get that
super chat remember we had a super chat
on a live show
uh on the playstation it was like one
last dude
oh yeah yeah that's my fault that's my
fault yeah i'm sorry yeah there was one
at the end of the state of play reaction
show uh
apologies on that i was supposed to
write that down so that's that's all me
y'all that's what i mean
but uh i'll look for it yeah it's
obviously caught up thanks
yeah we have uh spook with the final
chat thanks for all the fun times fellas
keep it up thank you
thank you all coming up yes sir all
right so let's get um petey now you're
on mute sir
and then uh as far as um your experience
yesterday in the mix
yes harvest what's going on yes uh i'll
try to uh i'll try to make this you know
it's as enjoyable as everybody if you
hear beeping in the background i am
sorry because i am on a battery backup
right now
trying to get this taken for you guys uh
because i wanted to make sure i came on
here and told you guys how much
i enjoyed playing the game and i i
played probably about
four or five hours of um just a single
player
and i loved it and i thought it was
really really good and and i
love the music the the art style
everything about it is fantastic and
then uh
being able to do that multiplayer map
with you guys
seeing just how how different
the single player is to the multiplayer
because
you think when you're doing a single
player campaign you know that's going to
be
very similar to how the multiplayer
campaign is but uh i'm sorry that's the
you know the multiplayer matches are
going to be and they are
totally completely different which i
really really enjoyed
seeing the dynamic of you know the three
of us going against
three veterans and then pretty much we
us getting stomped because
he got stopped especially you enjoyed it
especially when you got drafted in the
winning team
i don't remember who threw me to your
side was that addict if i recall
adequately let's go with your shot he
told me
shout out to elliot the game designer
who says look i just want to be clear
even though i'm going over to atticus
i have the statistically worst percent
win percentage
so no one believed it but it ended up
being true and i will agree with you
i misjudged the situation
and i don't think he expected sometimes
to be coming up against me and he was
just getting like stomped
and he didn't expect like seeing next on
our side so it's really really good to
see you know
how even just a little bit of um you
know guidance and showing what's going
to happen it kind of helps
you understand the game even more and
make you grow as a better player
and that was a you know a fantastic
thing to see and some of the new
elements and things
that i didn't even know were part of the
game
like for instance for instance this is
something so
simple and i've i've never even realized
like the sensory
the century turrets they had to be
rotated yes because most
most um rts games when you have like
bunkers
or you have turrets of some sort you
just place them and they just do
you know three uh 360 degrees around
them but not these you actually have to
place them in a certain direction which
is very very interesting
yeah man very cool stuff yeah yeah i
love that let me get this super chat
right now we got the legendary will me
hood with the 50
super chat thank you brother much love
to the realm my crew is doing a halo
stream and probably wondering where
you know much love for you being here
shout out to full gaming
gamer behind the box they're doing a
cool halo stream i try to uh
get in there man yeah salute to those
guys it's so cool so cool let me get
hulk right quick because i know hoagy
said you were familiar
with iron harvest obviously would you
work easy allies and promotions and
stuff like that
but um does that genre appeal to you as
a anything that with iron harvest did
you get a chance to take a look at
and see what's going on so i haven't
popped into it you know when they were
advertising on easy allies it was early
stages
um and and certainly when i talked to
yon at
king art uh they were still well away
from doing things we actually wound up
talking about things like
book of unwritten tales you know i'm an
adventure game guy i love this
i love this kind of stuff and king art
has been putting that kind of stuff out
for a while
um so i am interested it reminds me of a
board game i like called scythe
um in terms of art style and in terms of
what it's presenting and certainly it
looks like company of heroes to me from
a little bit more old school rts side of
things
so i'm following it but unfortunately i
haven't gotten a chance to play it i
haven't followed
the beta and um some of the folks that
follow me or that watch your show
probably don't know this but i'm
generally not an early access
type guy which is definitely going to
come up later in the show when we talk
about the fact that i just played the
avengers beta
all weekend but but then it's not a real
beta that game's done
i am uh i i'm just one that likes to let
things percolate let things get finished
my brother's the game designer that
likes to see things before they're done
but i
like to let them uh ripen a little bit
so i'm interested i love the art uh i
think
you know mechs in a world war type
environment is very very cool
um but i'm still waiting to see how it
uh how it turns out absolutely yeah
i'm gonna get it i must say that uh
thinking of kingdom come deliverance
before and on and
even slightly after release in what
state it was and
comparing it to iron harvest is actually
arizona harvest for me
of course i know where where things are
missing and where
where are bugs and so on but i must say
i feel like this
almost almost did so it's it's it's it's
an extremely good state
yeah very very good very glad to hear it
yeah man
so that's cool and um like i said uh
king uh sof
i know uh you guys got a chance to to
pop in
but as far as the aesthetic the look of
the game don't worry about the challenge
part just
the game it's going to get you guys
feeling all that
well i feel like onto something um i saw
the level of fun that they was having
and i think from a streaming aspect um
it's definitely something fun to stream
and watch yeah um because you can sit
there and be like oh man get him
get him and you're like why is he doing
that
and i'm sitting there with a level of
frustration eating some chips and i know
i know when i'm doing something bad am i
and i'm intense with something
because i'm eating chips i'm not
supposed to eat chips right so i'm like
oh no no
no and i knew what was going on at that
moment i was like they got my nerves up
and i knew i was invested in the game
not just by the people that i knew that
was there that was playing it
because it's a point in time where that
blurs out and you're just watching the
game right
and you're just trying to figure out
what the hell is his next move and then
when you when you're seeing the moves
happen you're like
oh man don't be that stupid and then
when they crush your team you like ah
bye
but you knew going in what it was it was
like a heavyweight fight and you knew
the challenger really didn't have a shot
but you was hoping that he was going to
do it and he was praying that he was he
was he was uh what was that not john
ruiz
what was that uh other spanish fighter
that just won
i was hoping one of them would land a
serious blow and knock him out
i was like please come on man all i know
is
added for c was definitely disappointing
i knew we were in trouble
when i speak to toby pre-match and he
goes
so you know if we're going to do it our
you know um
he said you sure you don't want to break
your teeth because after we squash you
we might want to make it more
competitive and get one of our guys or
you're out of line oh no
i didn't want to disrespect i just
wanted to do it
he said because you said an hour
i love how people act like i was the
only one on the team
ultimate game player so sorry i'm i'm
sorry i i love how that's how i view you
i'm the only one on the team apparently
i for the majority of the match i was
the only one really having filled
presents but
i don't know on the issue here okay no
no no
you you kept the balance but i say this
because i talked to cog
way before this right and me and him was
joking off street
that see before it even started i knew
where toby and his team was at with it
when they said with one of his team
members said
they was given a name because i forget
the names of the the the um the squads
right
and he was like this squad is the elite
squad that's why i'm taking him
yeah so shout out to elliot yeah shout
out that he was talking spicy
he was he was classic man he was a real
elliot is amazing
yes he is very knowledgeable we got a
lot of background he
definitely answered a ton of questions
for our console community they
definitely were interested in the game
and for the record toby it's coming to
console at some point
exactly yeah and for attic saying i do
not want to be playing nobody with candy
mouse
i mean get keyboard and rounds because
they have a hell of an advantage
you know i was screaming at the tv facts
facts when you're playing the game on
like as i play halo wars 2 on pc and
xbox
and on pc you know you you just click on
the mini map and it takes you straight
to there
like on console you have to literally
like scroll
manually up there like all that stuff
absolutely i see so
i'm gonna get these super chats and then
i want to get uh undead back here
oh yeah five dollars okay we got five
dollars from spaceman
fred grows everything around me phil get
the money
www y'all wow
all right smitty smitty's in his bag you
already know
but i'm dead man before i give it back
to tony like just again like
what other things you learned about it
you know in the experience of just the
game itself
one of the things i really actually
enjoyed about the the game itself
and something that i didn't find with a
lot of rts games like one of the most
frustrating things about rts games is
like
when you're first learning the game you
usually get stomped by your friends
playing it but you don't really
necessarily adapt and learn from it
but after the first two like kickings
that toby gave me i kind of started
changing the changing
i started changing up my strategy and
going okay so
if i go aggressively to this point i
know the field in this area
gives me a better defensive position so
if i start from here and then go in this
way
instead of going directly in i start
having different results and better
results and then
like the only thing i wasn't catching on
to was building the max up fast enough
to keep pace with everybody else
but i think that's really cool about
this game is the fact that after three
matches i felt like i was infinitely
better
yeah than when i started
did you notice like the statistics at
the end like in the statistics in the
end it kind of also showed you
how much better we were playing yeah
because they were getting better and
higher and higher
each time and that was very cool to be
able to see that yeah good good i did
uh i i me and elliot need to have a
conversation at some point because
somehow he went for
he was the top of their team for two
rounds he comes and plays with me an
addict and somehow he's like
yeah so me and elliot need to have that
words
but for realistically like i absolutely
love
rts games and the fact of i cannot
give enough credit to how polished this
game is
and how polished it was when they
released the prior steam demo i wrote a
piece on it and i was like for a game
that
is months from release this is butter
smooth and like this demo right now you
could tell me this is full release and i
believe
you believe it it ran flawlessly we had
no connect we had no issues we had no
dropouts
it ran flawlessly and i really commend
the developers on that because i know
that's a really really hard thing to do
especially when you have something where
you're trying to make an enticing single
player campaign
while also trying to balance and make
the multiplayer compelling and
interesting and everything else so i
just want to really give king art games
thank you i will make sure to send these
warm words to the studio
however you know what's really
interesting how you said that you got
better and better each match i i
i totally sent the same thing because
king david was saying
that when he gets nervous he starts to
eat to eat
chips when i get nervous i start to get
to become totally silent and
i get a face that's the focus that's the
focus focus
focus and lean forward right after that
the devs were asking they would tell
toby's quiet and i could tell that third
match it was intense you were focused
i was i had i had to focus like like
real like that was that was i i would
not agree that you would
crush me i would i would i would conquer
that
because i was prepared i was actually
preparing for you coming to my base
which
you did not but i was preparing for that
but however you made me sweat and you
make me go silent so that's
definitely yeah we're going to keep
bringing up how i didn't finish here we
got to keep doing it
the funny thing was that that sort of
like i know king uses this a lot with
the pincer move but the moment when
undead was pushing forward and then you
see toby pull back i said i'm dead he
he caught you like you baby he turned
you
in he baited you in oh no
he's exposed you know where stuff
started going like south at the
beginning for toby
like if you look at that uh that match
you'll see
me be like man they're over here doing
some wrong stuff to my dude on dead
and i literally went the long way around
and i flaked
uh flake toby and toby was trying to
retreat with his hero
i was like oh there's a hero i gotta
kill that thing
can we just talk about the fact that i
what i loved about addict's play from
the third game
was he was like barracks nah we don't
need that we're going straight to max we
don't need anything
you know what you get you get addicted
right to the power of those backs man
yeah and what's funny is i didn't say
none of that at the beginning like
like the reason that i was like i don't
need a barracks is because
at the end of the second game they
pushed on me what you really need
and it was talking spicy to you at that
point too i was like i don't
remember them using infantry to push on
me at the end
so you know what i ain't building a
barracks right now
and then within like 15 minutes i had
like eight or nine
mechs and then like because that that's
what i caught toby off guard
yeah exactly exactly
you all died so yeah
well i like so like even in the
beginning how you can have your you know
your reserved troops
push out so like you can pick pretty
much like troops that you want
and if you've noticed every single time
everybody was picking like different
types of matchups too
so they had like different heroes and
different like extra troops to bring in
i thought it was a real cool different
change also yeah really cool that great
time
great stream absolutely amazing again if
you guys
missed it it's up on the iron podcast
youtube channel
check it out the iron challenge you know
what i'm saying
with the uh kick our games toby and of
course the laws man so much fun told me
i just want to let i want you to let the
people know again
where we are right now how far we are
out in the development cycle i know the
beta is out right now so if you can
educate the people okay so as you said
right now we iron harvest is in the open
beta so feel free to go to the steam
page of king
earth of iron harvest just look it up
and you can immediately download the
game it's for free you can try it there
single player missions there's you can
play multiplayer the lobby is full right
now so you don't have long
long times to wait um there is a
skirmish and single player challenges so
there's really
a lot of stuff for beta i must say and
of course right now and that's maybe
also interesting um the esl the uh
i don't know what's that i don't know
what esl actually means
yeah it's boss is it esports league yeah
maybe maybe
esports league so they are they're
organizing
right now as we speak they have a iron
harvest
tournament going on and the interesting
thing is yeah
and the interesting thing is it's filled
not with pros but it's like with
randoms who want to be part of this
league and it's free to still enter that
tournament
and you can win up to uh prices up to
seven thousand dollars so really nice
there's a lot of
a lot of things that i'll be joining
today
that's perfect because addict i want to
see you in the in the finale because
the finale of uh the esports tournament
the iron harvest tournament will take
place at digital gamescom
by the end of august where i will travel
to cologne to germany and i will be
casting and hosting this this uh finales
and we'll be as a moderator there so
addict uh
next saturday is the is qualifier number
two so you can still jump in and go at
it
come over deep we got to redeem our
honor he's putting it on your back right
now
[Laughter]
so the beta will be up and running till
release so you can from today till
release you can play iron harvest every
day if you like it awesome and the game
releases
on september 1st which is one month from
now
three weeks or so one two three
three three weeks and a few days and
then the
game releases and of course as always if
you pre-order you get stuff there's a
collector's edition
there's actually there's a collector's
edition with an
actual iron in there like really ironing
iron
or like an iron iron
we go so you can get you cleaned your
clothes because
you get leaned out you get pressed you
know like the super
old one the one you had to preheat on
some stove or something
like nice uh and why not right
exactly i guess there's really a lot of
stuff in there and we are looking
forward to meet you all and of course
as always if you have any questions go
to the social media
or to the gourd of iron harvest it's
easy to find
absolute pleasure man toby in the realm
it's a shame
we can't physically meet each other like
because it's a silly pandemic
but it is really cool to have you in the
realm man again for the realm iron
harvest you're hurting here first we'll
put a lot of that information attic will
put a lot of that information
in chat so people can sign up and get
interested as well as the open beta
toby like i said you're more than
welcome to hang out but i know if you
got things you got to do it's all good
we're going to get into the rest of the
show
what an absolute pleasure brother man
that was a lot of fun yesterday
thank you it was definitely a lot of fun
absolutely
especially for especially at equal
fatigue i
had it for c it wasn't that fun
especially for peter who got drafted in
the winning team
and i would like to say i helped keep
elliot at bay i want to thank you
that i did hold him back for you hey but
i must say
really like seriously no no no [ __ ] talk
right now you all played really good no
jokes i mean in the
always the same when you played in the
beginning you you don't know all the
tricks and mechanics and so on
but as someone of you said earlier it
really just
this one little hint about retreating
about like walking backwards and
on different turns to turning around
your barracks
and bunkers and so on these little
tricks already makes you make you so
much better and i think the learning
curve is
pretty good there and absolutely all
right
thanks a lot man thank you very much
gentlemen do it put the description in
the chat and again toby thank you so
much brother
always a pleasure
high five everyone high five brother we
know we see each other
very soon i can't wait to get to germany
yes
yes man when real gays call back yeah uh
yeah cognito you promised me that we
will meet one day
oh yeah it's happening no the lord's
going to germany
oh yeah we already know we're going plus
i got to get some drinks overseas
2021 then yes it is what it is whenever
it happens we gonna be there because
trust me right now we got that travel
itch we are supposed to have been in
california
we were supposed to be getting ready to
go to gamescom so
all this is doing is making us stronger
that's all that's it perfect
all right brother have a good gentleman
i'm lifting my head for you have a great
evening
see you guys
[Music]
yesterday too they say on monday monday
the latest
yeah i hope so question marks yeah yeah
have a good one baby
later guys all right max solve you want
to get that uh
i got disconnected for a little bit okay
did
i'm back though did we get the smitty
smith one oh yes we got somebody smith
let me get a forte oh he got a shout out
shout out to forte great to see the
lords on this fire setting
sunday in michigan plus the stream was
great
love the energy hello to my fellow
michigander
hoglong that's right see
you know you got you're out there with
northville michigan and then you find
every other potential or former
michigander on the internet it's all
good stuff
absolute pleasure man [ __ ] get in the
realm we already know so we go
move on get into the rest of the show
so um let's get the poll question
actually last week's poll results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question with the recent
success of grounded and microsoft ips
having great initial success on steam
do you think this pressure so needs to
put more first party playstation
exclusives on pc sooner than later
the winner of the three-way ilp pro at
51 percent
is no sony still values their console
ecosystem more than
xbox group coming in
second place at 33 33 of the vote was
sony values extra profit only a matter
of time
group in last place with only 14 of the
vote was i don't care
if they put all my exclusives on pc
master race i'm throwing playstation in
the bushes
shout out to all the lawyers who
participated last week um lord undead
i need your thoughts on this whole steam
sales and initial success well yeah with
this man
you see why love is i love all the
people that try to like miscredit steam
sales charts yeah i saw i saw
a certain individual was trying to do
this with some of our articles in your
poll
yeah um is well how much copies does it
really take to become
the steam best seller and nonsense like
this
the thing is for a game to be a top
seller in steam it's impressive in
itself because there's so
many games on steam people don't really
grasp how many games release on steam a
day
i think on average you can count like 10
to 15 early access games a day
so try and get your head above water
with that is it's really hard
yeah but you cannot deny the fact
that when playstation microsoft put
their games on the pc store
they stay in the top selling list for a
long
time microsoft last week and the week
before that and the week before that
four of the top five best-selling games
on steam were their games
thief sold one million copies at the
price
what'd you say again i can't what did
you say my headset went out
so see i mean i really didn't hear you
so so four four out of the five best
selling games on steam for the past few
weeks have been microsoft published
games
the success that microsoft has found on
steam is
incredible in the fact of unlike
playstation
where you don't necessarily have like pc
game pass or anything like that like
playstation now works on pc but very
restrictive and limited
um for sea of thieves for example which
is an old game came out in 2018
launched on steam just um just a little
bit over a month ago
has already sold a million copies and
they've had
they've had the most success of that
game in the past
three months um grounded was the
best-selling game on steam for the week
of its release
github um grounded was the best-selling
game of his release
and even when you go to playstation
games like death stranding horizon
zero dawn right now
like horizon zero dawn the pc port is a
little bit messy and it's a little bit
all over the place but that
is still the top selling game
on steam and they're charging fifty
dollars for something you can buy on the
playstation store for five dollars
right so that's crazy and the thing is
is people think that
exclusivity is what will drive these
companies if companies start realizing
they can make
10 million dollars off playing their
game on pc they will
right even atlas after releasing persona
4 golden which is a game from 2012
i believe or 2010 i don't even know how
old that game is it's almost a decade
old
they put that game on steam and it sold
close to a million copies in a month
absolutely so no company like if i tell
you hey you have this product that a lot
of people love
i'm gonna put on another platform i'm
gonna make you 10 million dollars
right what are you going to say to that
exactly that might be
a little too easy
well i mean i think one thing that is a
part of this right we've obviously
talked about this for a number of months
which is the different approaches
between microsoft and sony here is the
timing component
right there's a distinction between
microsoft releasing grounded on steam
day and date with its release on xbox
and sony releasing horizon zero dawn
whatever i don't know when zero dawn
came out 17
yeah 2017. so i i do think sony will
continue to explore this
uh effectively well we have taken all
the money we can from our console
ecosystem so now release it to the pc
people
but i think that's a distinct philosophy
difference
between xbox and sony so sony probably
will i don't see sony moving that window
back pretty much i see sony
treating the pc essentially as home
video and playstation 4 is the theater
or playstation 5. yeah no it's two
philosophy things
i think i think the issue hulk just came
down to you know
we wanted to do is just recognize
initial success depending on whoever the
platform
holder is on oh yeah because thief is
just crazy
exactly thieves is just crazy i saw how
many months it was up there
um that's just crazy i love sea of
thieves i really do and
they they should be commended for taking
what was
frankly weaker than destiny day one and
making it a very strong product
absolutely um but i was i was very
surprised to see that level
of engagement with full price pc sales
no question
yeah like i said that's all it is i mean
to me it's just more of a celebration
of you know another platform literally
you know having success with these games
you know
all it shows me is that no matter what
the pc gamer doesn't care about the
console
space until the game reaches their
ecosystem that's what
when i when i say if a tree falls in the
forest do you hear it like a lot of
times people tell me stuff is on
playstation
uh now oh oh you're excited is in game
pass if that was on playstation now like
a month ago
i'm like okay i would not know and i
would not care because that's not where
i came at and i wouldn't give them money
on that service
that's the same way the pc guy is it's
like oh what's the zero horizon doing
maybe he never even un
knew that it was on playstation maybe he
doesn't even care about what's going on
on the playstation
and he clicked and he purchased at full
price because he thinks it's a brand new
game
right he doesn't know that oh i can get
a playstation oh if i have a playstation
i can play it on my playstation now for
five dollars it doesn't occur to him
and it's not even in his thought pattern
so when you lock yourself up your stuff
off
into one ecosystem and you don't
capitalize on money
that's in another space that's a limit
in your corporation and when your
corporation starts to realize what
you're doing
i'm pretty sure you're gone what
fascinated me about the microsoft side
of things is that like sea of thieves
exists on game pass
pc ultimate like right now it's the same
you're still playing it on your pc
um you just aren't buying a full price
version on steam so it surprised me that
there wasn't what i would have thought
was a bigger
divot in their sales that's what i would
surprise be too good
when it comes down to it let me mute my
music when it comes down to it
they i think microsoft knows that
there's a lot of people that will take
advantage of game pass ultimate and
download it
but there's a lot of steam fan boys
and they know for a fact that as long as
they release it on steam
they will come so some people yeah gabe
is tithe and you make some sales yeah
yeah i think that that was their point
they're like look we'll make game pass
we'll give
value on ultimate to make sure people
want to
pay that 15 a month to have access to
both ecosystems but we know
that there is way more steam fanboys
on pc than there are people that will
get it on gamepad
there's people let's be real like
there's people like it's a good point
out there's people that even when the
epic story came into play you know a lot
of the pc community was like look that's
nice and all but i like steam i like
this ecosystem i like my friend list i
feel that the feature set
is more superior to epic i i would get
an argument because as a console guy
initially i'm looking at it like
why wouldn't you get this game that's
free over there just to open another
launcher they're like no
they don't want it it's a huge deal they
were like we
are staying here with our launches so
that's all it is man so the polls just
about
uh celebrating success and seeing what's
going on in the industry that's it but
we're gonna move on into
these topics and uh this is a hot one
man we got hogan
you know we gotta talk about it we're
having uh sorry
we have big cloud gaming with the ten
dollar super chat put those ttl gamers
in their place
a lot of tcl you know it is true
because a lot of times i i keep telling
the tcl gamer listen y'all
you guys are covered we we sort of specs
everything is out
um 1440p checkerboard you don't even
have to worry about that i need help on
tcl
don't don't worry about it you're good
uh the playstation 5
has you covered if you have a tcl you
don't have to worry about upgrading
anything if you're a playstation gamer
you're safe you're good but if you have
an x i i
really uh will tell you to um upgrade oh
unless you're gonna get the lockhart
okay
they do have some 120 frames per second
i don't i wouldn't trust that i wouldn't
trust that
spiderman i wouldn't trust that no it's
not 4k
it's not 4k it's checkerboard but i
can't
addicts tcl headset
and no we have a few more actually we
have dj hero with the five dollar super
chat
thank the lords for the constant
entertainment ifp community is the best
community hashtag take them knees
thank you sir
[Music]
then we have regulator 951 with the 5
super chat
chris hart over here saying game pass
devalues games and doesn't encourage the
devs to make great games
please can get this man's needs real
quick no we're gonna have to leave
christopher hart alone he's been bashed
up all week i mean that state of plate
was horrible
he's in the dumps right now it was
abysmal and i feel sorry for my guy
please uh check on christopher hart make
sure he's okay
please everybody put hearts in the arm
yeah i do i do feel like we located a
wellness check man
i feel like any playstation fan watching
that
they need a welding check man we need a
little hashtag
there we have jay riddy with the five
dollar super chat shout out to game pass
devil may cry 5 leaving 8 14
play it yeah if you haven't played it no
if you haven't played it and it's been
there
damn near yeah yeah full yeah go buy it
right now it's on the super cheap too
would you get
10 off go get it man then we have
jd gamer with the five dollar super chat
microsoft has a great deal with game
pass for its fans
then the games still sell well on steam
so it's all
covered just imagine anyway i'm getting
moved here just imagine what the new
triple a's will sell
that is true then we uh we got a new
member in the realm man uh put those
put those uh put the crest in the chat
welcome to the realm the wise one
no i just heard the homeless too i just
heard the whole that was that was me
with their mouths
heart so i could put it in there for you
put the horse in the round man that's
what's up man
recording no he wants hearts in the uh
heart you know you know i'm gonna put a
heart what i'm gonna put this one in
there there you go put the broken heart
in there you're gonna put it in the car
yeah
there you go on your heart
yes sir we're caught up all right okay
no we're not
stop ripping on my bedroom tv kings
yo listen listen as long as it stays in
the bedroom once it makes its way
outside yo we got
we got problems
a lot of tcl slander going on today but
look man this has been a hot one
we have got spider-man man uh coming to
marvel's avengers exclusively
on playstation i don't know why king is
laughing
and according to uh the the blog post
it's never been a better time to be a
spider-man fan
the team at crystal dynamics along with
our partners
are overjoyed that we get to be a part
of this hero's
journey we can't wait for you to add
spider-man to your marvel avengers
roster
first and er gotta get this first in
early 2021
as we promised before he will be
available at no additional cost
to owners of the base game exclusively
on playstation so that was the news that
rockley on dead face right now it's
classic
that was the news that rocked the
industry this week and it had
been everybody to tizzy some people were
a tizzy but i want to get it off to a
hog man because
he had an outstanding virtue legality
right now going i believe it was our
274.
and let's break it down hogan you know
what are your thoughts on all this
and i'm going to create a new hashtag
lord help us hug yeah there you go help
us
yeah yeah so i did a video on this
because
if if you actually follow the timing
this all came out or was leaked or was
rumored just before it came out at the
same time that sony came out and said
you all have to buy new controllers as
many as we want to sell you uh
really at the same time right um and so
the point of the video that i made and
really the point of this whole
conversation is that
sony's in a different business than
microsoft right this second
and they're in the business of locking
people down uh in a way that microsoft
isn't and so this kind of thing this
sales of
exclusivity of spider-man on their side
of the the pond
uh of of console sales is something that
we should get to be expecting this
this is this is going to be what sony
does and right now the market for these
kinds of exclusives
is probably cut in half they might be a
market of one for really the companies
that are looking to do this
and so it wouldn't surprise me if this
continues on
now i called it in my video
anti-consumer
on a broad basis not that you
necessarily have to come out and
and gnash your teeth and rend your
garments and cry to the wind
but that just on kind of a basis of
direct
competition with their nearest
competitor it is clearly more
anti-consumer
than what microsoft is trying to do and
this isn't talking about the content to
where god of war lives or anything else
so please
you can leave that to the comments in
virtual legality i i look forward to the
insults
but what the point of this conversation
is
microsoft saying you don't have to buy a
new controller sony's saying that you do
that's sony is just more
anti-consumerist than microsoft on a
question like that
and if we assume that crystal dynamics
would have been perfectly happy putting
the most popular marvel character in
history
on both sides of the multi-platform
release of their game
then sony essentially just paid money to
make sure that microsoft didn't have it
for the most part and at a broad level i
don't mind it i was probably always
going to get it on sony anyway
but it's it's not great i like to see
everybody have
the best experience possible i hated it
when microsoft bought tomb raider away
i hate it when sony bought spider-man
away right no this is both square enix
they're they're bad at this
and and so when we have these
conversations
i can understand folks that are upset i
can understand folks
also i can understand sony likes to you
know kind of stoke the fires of the
console war a little bit
i understand the folks say aha you don't
get it
to some personality that that makes
sense that it somehow
captures more value on their side of the
console war because the other
side doesn't get something right broadly
speaking i think in multi-platform
titles and i felt this since the
exclusive deals for destiny
i don't think this makes sense
psychologically i don't think it's good
marketing
um and i think really when we talk about
something like this
sony isn't likely to sell playstation 5s
they are likely to
slightly bump up their sales of this
specific game on their platform
but for 30 of just marvel's avengers
sales
i don't i don't like this look but i
certainly understand that there are some
people that just like to feel like
um how do i put this delicately that
that sony is putting their boot on the
throat
and they want to back a horse that is
just destructive of the other side's
ends um and so i think sony plays into
that a little bit i would expect this to
continue for the
next year at minimum um and so i do
think that's a harbinger of
um the use of resources that could have
been spent on things that would better
the industry that would get me more
products that i like
being used instead just to line the
pockets of various publishers
to hold things back from other people
and that's never going to make me
thrilled
no i understand your position on this
talk but i i want to be fair and i want
to
sure i want to give you some counters in
reference to okay two things one what
i love counters what do you say you know
we gotta have fun come on
you know uh what do you say to people
who say look this is
sony caring about their fan base and
investing to give their base
something right that's number one so the
only thing that i so again we'll just do
these in order right okay so
we can have some some problem with this
i i always am amenable to this argument
when it is clear that the thing in
question wouldn't have existed
okay right i'm i'm amenable to this
argument for
uh nintendo's saying that nobody was
interested in making marvel ultimate
alliance until we ponied up a hundred
million dollars
it's that game is definitely not a
hundred million dollars whatever money
they had to pony up to get that game
made
i am totally amenable to that kind of
concept which is just
in the corporate world we would think of
it as outsourced research and
development
you just paid for it it's a
collaboration agreement and exists
because you paid for it and so naturally
it's yours just as much as god of war
isn't going to appear on the xbox
anytime soon you just basically paid for
a game to be made
it just so happened to be outside but
we're here
where we've got a character and one
thing i will say about this i don't know
if we're going to talk about actually
our feelings on the beta or how many of
you have played it
but having played the beta this weekend
and this was pretty evident from the war
table videos that they did
a character is a big freaking deal in
avengers
a character is a destiny class yes it is
it is
nine skill trees it is a loot table it
is an interaction with every other hero
it is its own battle pass as we saw in
the beta
it is a big big big deal so this isn't
just
uh two months of map access in call of
duty
it isn't just a gun skin it isn't just
that kind of thing this is an actual
we're gonna hack off what is a
significant part
of the game experience and we're not
gonna allow microsoft players to have it
it's just not ever something i'm going
to really love okay okay
and again i did i get just to double
down from a pure
business stand double down right
people will say that it is just business
right that it is just
sony had phone it up and if microsoft
had that same opportunity
they should have ponied up so my my up
my other question is in reference to
that what do you say that and then
who the simplest question is who took
the bag
because there's a lot of confusion here
right there's there's you know
spider-man the character
you know the the the movie character
with the writers oh the legal stuff
yeah i do that in the video as well yeah
i almost did a secondary video saying no
sony doesn't own spider-man
yeah that's a fair question um so
uh starting at the end yeah i think it
takes two to tango
i mean i really do think that marvel and
disney had to agree with sony
and they both had to kind of say yep
this makes sense and as i said i brought
up tomb raider because square enix is
known for making stupid decisions with
its business
uh and so i do think this is one of
those
again heck when this game releases
giving crystal dynamics the avengers
license might be stupid
at the entirety of the project but in
terms of just that then i think that
what we're talking about here
is uh sony and marvel agreeing
and the secondary question that you had
was why didn't microsoft pay up
yes microsoft could have paid up i think
there's a relationship issue there which
we can talk about vis-a-vis spider-man
particularly
right but one thing that i would impress
upon your audience and then this panel
is that money being spent on exclusives
whether it's microsoft's or sony's
i don't care that's deadweight cost to
our game experience
that is not money developing new content
that is not money that makes our games
better that's money
that goes to a publisher to make
somebody else's game
worse and whether or not microsoft or
sony is outbidding each other
in that kind of conversation i don't
care i i say this in virtual legality
all the time but i'm not backing a horse
on this gotcha thankfully i'm pretty
blessed
in my income level i'm going to get both
yeah we got everything right
you know and so i i want the best
games possible to be made my commentary
when halo infinite was shown was not
oh man xbox sucks now we can rag on them
it was man i wish halo looked better
i want to be more excited about that
thing you know and so i want everything
to be great
and so the question that you ask is why
didn't microsoft bid more yeah maybe
they could have
but i really don't want to be engaging
in what amounts to a deadweight loss
where we're just
spending more and more money to not make
gains um i'm sorry not fair enough i
have two more questions that i'll open
it up to the panel
sure this is great yeah so pretty much
now you made another point
and we know the spider-man video game
character
existed on the switch i have marvel
ultimate alliance three on switch yes
spider-man's running loose around is
there's no problem
you know yeah he's in marvel versus
capcom multiplayer exactly so
yeah is it a situation where
sony allowed that to for him to appear
or was this like a pre-deal thing before
yeah you know like it's just this weird
gray area of how come he's there but
he's not here
and you know it's just weird right yeah
so let's back this down
to like some fundamental notions right
because this came out on social media
and twitter my comments and everywhere
else
one marvel owned spider-man okay
when you have the intellectual property
rights in a piece of property
you have the right to license out the
use of that property without selling it
right even when marvel was going
bankrupt in the 90s
they retained the rights to spider-man
that's why he had comic books and
everything else
and so they they retain the right to
spider-man and they
exclusively licensed the right to make
spider-man movies to sony pictures
that's what happened in the 90s sony
pictures then went and made the same
the best decisions they've ever made
well you got the sam ramy spider-man and
you get you know claire dunst and her
horrible mary jane
and goku andrew garfield
you go through andrew garfield and one
of the worst movies ever made with
amazing spiders and finally
you want spider-man 2. amazing
spider-man 1 is is mediocre amazing
spider-man 2 is one of the worst thing
i've ever had
but then you get to tom holland and then
you start to get people really really
confused right
because what's happened contractually at
that point in time is that disney and
marvel are essentially
borrowing spider-man and share sharing
some of the revenues and then agreeing
to i think creatively develop the movies
on sony's behalf it's a very complex
relationship on top of all that back in
the 90s the actual license that happened
here is something like 170 pages long
it got leaked out when the sony email
leads happened you can check it out
online
it's a ridiculous contract i would never
draft it that way sony if you're
listening i'm happy i'm available
yeah no but you look at that license
it's way too long but
one of the things that comes out is when
you get to insomniac wanting to make a
spider-man game yes
let's say about 2015 or so yeah when
they're looking at what they want to
make to release 2018 spider-man
marvel is a part of that licensing sony
is a part of that licensing
they already have a relationship between
their entities
that is important it's not legal it's
important because it's a vice
vice president that knows a vice
president it's a business strategist
that knows a business strategist
they are comfortable with each other yes
and so
there is some kind of other contract
some kind of other license that happens
right then and there
to make the insomniac marvel spider-man
game and when insomniac makes that game
it doesn't mean that insomniac and sony
because we're just going to treat him
the same because sony would later buy
insomniac
right that they don't that they own
spider-man they don't own spider-man
what they do have are certain rights
to the specifics of the version of
spider-man that they developed for 120
million which is the insomniac
version we call him white spider yeah
there we go
white spider sony has certain rights too
so
marvel can't just take white spider in
all likelihood this is all based on a
contract we can't see
so marvel is unlikely to be able to take
white spider and say you know what
we're putting that game on the xbox sony
has those rights right
and so in all likelihood a couple of
things happened here
okay one the crystal dynamics avengers
game
is in my opinion not likely to directly
reference the insomniac game
but is is likely to be built in a
fashion in which
nothing contravenes the background
for insomniac spider-man that this very
well could be insomniac spider-man he
might talk about back in new york a
bunch which is normal for spider-man
right right he might reference a few
things there's nothing that you couldn't
obliquely reference that happened in the
2018 spider-man game right
that would be something that wouldn't
work in the avengers game
i would also expect the white spider
costume to show up uh in in the avengers
version
on spider-man at the same time sony says
spider-man's associated with our brand
heck the playstation 3 logo was
the sam raimi spider-man logo that's
correct and
we want this to only be on our platform
and we're willing to pay you x amount of
dollars
at which point square enix says well
that's a lot of money thanks sony
and we'll agree to it because we don't
ever think about our decisions and that
tomb raider thing is now a couple years
back so nobody remembers it
so i really do think what happened was
strategic relationships
i do think that it related to the fact
that sony wants to keep pushing
spider-man so sony was always in favor
of having spider-man added to the game
right and then they weren't so keen
on necessarily having it over on the
microsoft platform
and thought it would be a good
differentiator like i said
my best guess is that you're looking at
a year of multi-plats getting
exclusivity stuff on playstation you
literally answered my next question
because
the the same thing i was going to say
was in reference to the
again we're speculating we're not seeing
this contract but you know we will never
see this kind of
never but i haven't seen intellectual
property contract so i can tell you
what they look like at least in broad
strokes right so in this case which is
uh which was we led into perfectly
which would be permanent exclusivity
or timed exclusivity based on i think
they would have said times
okay now being that i don't recall them
saying timed
they didn't right right so in this vein
this would be different this would be he
would never
appear on microsoft platform or the pc
version of avengers by the based on
again we're speculating
based on the nature of what we think
this uh they're pretty good sony sony's
not perfect but they're pretty good
about
saying you know for now or
they don't use the word timed usually
they use different english language
words that mean timed mostly
on playstation first it plays first that
kind of stuff
um so i you read that and it looks very
much to me like it's
it's permanent yes um but again you know
it's
it's such a big chunk of what that game
has to offer
yeah it's uh it's wild it's a wild deal
so that
real money real money change channels no
money change hands man so let's
open it up man undead i listened to
gaming perspective last night and you
had a lot of things to say
in regards to this you know you're very
animated so let's get right into it then
we open up to the lawrence man
you know what you're feeling on this
whole thing no deal
big deal people blowing out of
proportion wait
uh well see here's my thing is i'm not
gonna be one of those people that
pretended like this game was a big deal
to me in the first place
it's because of this because i've been
covering this game since its reveal and
it's the most
average and triple a-ish game i've ever
seen in my life i object
that home became judgemental enough
um there's just something that does not
enter i'm not a huge marvel guy that's
the main thing
i'm not a big marvel guy like i like
spider-man yada yada
the game just hasn't really drawn me in
no no um but
i don't mind exclusivity deals like i
guess part of the business
for the most part and like hope so
eloquently put
i don't think people realize how much
money gets pissed away on these
exclusivity deals that could be going to
making
better experiences for us um but the
biggest thing i'm not a fan of
well i mean undead they did say uh sony
did say they're gonna be giving you less
content did they not say that
see my here's my thing and this is my
only thing with this i don't mind deals
like the medium with blooper team with
xbox where they're like hey
we're gonna give you a bag so you can
make this game yes i don't mind
sony money hatting death loop for one
year exclusivity because it's a whole
game i get i'm with you now
my my problem as a whole is
when you're selling a 60 game on three
platforms
but two of those platforms don't get
content because they choose to play on
different platforms this definitely
encouraged people to buy a playstation
because if you went and buy go and buy a
playstation 4 or a playstation 5
to paste play spider-man in 2021 on
marvel's avengers you're an idiot
um but the thing is is like
exclusive games are fine i get it you
need to make your software portfolio as
appealing as possible to your consumer
base
right but there is nothing good and to
be celebrated about
about other people paying the same price
you pay for a game
and they get less content that's period
and historic
this isn't sony treating you as
first-class citizens which i've seen
that
thrown around today spicy
last few days this isn't this is doesn't
care
sony microsoft they don't care about you
having console war points or whatever
the case may be
this is them wanting to see how much
money they can throw in a bag
and run away with it and square enix
needs to figure out what the hell
they're doing because spoiler alert when
final fantasy 16 comes out
and it's exclusive to playstation
because that's going to happen
it really makes the past year where
square enix has been playing
final fantasy on everything to be like
hey
don't you love all these final fantasy
games aren't they so great
oh nevermind they're exclusive over here
again square enix likes money
the tomb raider thing was ridiculous
they're doing things with marvel's
avengers now they're going to do they
just
if people will give square enix money to
do something
they're going to take the bag
they're going to take the bag that's
the bag of money and run with it no
matter what like
if if nintendo was like hey we want
i don't know some game from square
enix's back catalog is exclusive
square is not gonna be like i don't know
what about the fans they're gonna be how
much
and that's just how business is and i
understand that
yeah but i don't think like if you're
upset about this because you only play
on xbox and pc i respect you
if you play a playstation you're like i
don't mind this because i own a
playstation
i respect that but do not say this is a
good idea
don't oh you're taking it you're taking
all the stuff i'm about to say
don't don't applaud square enix and
sony for taking content away from other
people because if you celebrate
other people not being able to play
someone spoiler alert
you're a loser and that's all i would
say about it
period end of story see a dead
capped off i'm done
listen can i go next well before we go
let you get your balls but
we got to get the super chats we missed
a ton yeah we got to catch up
we have elemento pio with the five
dollar super chat why do i see people
duping on godfall throw it in the bushes
i agree
uh pixel bit g with the five dollar
super chat i pre-ordered avengers for
xbox one x
i cancelled my order we'll wait to see
if the ps4 pro version is inferior
before deciding if i want to pay for
this
right okay then we have brat with the
two dollar snapchat
hoge law in the house salute lords
hello brad what's going on then we have
regulator with the two dollar super chat
give me craig way better than spike
shout out to craig shout out to craig
that's great
um then we got black ronin with the 5
super chat
the spidey deal is great for ps5 players
and shite for consumers in general
if this goes further making third-party
characters exclusive on a multi-plat
he said it's ps5 players
what i don't know well i didn't see this
yeah
yeah he said ps5 players you mean ps4
brother
oh my lord that's going to be carried
over to ps5 there ain't nothing being
carried over
it's it's a gays this is the service you
think it's just gonna stay on yeah i
think it's gonna die right there
let's just oh no i don't i don't
disagree with you on there he's
definitely gonna be dead by the ps5
oh god objects
oh man you're trying to get it over to
the next station
you guys have doubted me on these type
of games we have the division we have
anthem
listen every game like this that i have
taken away from
this i'm telling you right now
he's compared it to act of hogue it is
anthem is anthem part
i i'd rather play tetris
then we have shane tomlin with the five
pound super chat this should clear up
chris's heart i hear a rumor that bucks
nice to have spider-man in it the book
event
love peace
with the ten dollar super chat by the
way i did get your email so your hat is
on the way expected in the next year or
so
nice um
back to next year would this play an
exclusivity deal with the next gen
narrative that multiplats will look and
play better on the series x
sony will counter with with these deals
x cod
nba 2k and others when you leave
powerful
undead in the house don't ask hogan
about mass effect
yeah don't let's not let's continue
pc master race lord chocolata
flip-flop then we have
face style we got that we have face with
e5
superchat blame xbox they showed sony
the blueprint in the 360 era and sony
ran with it yes that's
part of what i'm going to say with xbox
trying to change the playbook
yes sir um then we have broken games hdr
bc the ten dollar super chat the winning
platform will have more pull and more
contact bg you're taking my damn
you want better than buy better it will
buy a better four and you won't be
disappointed
the only reason you get somebody gets
away with this because xbox fails to
compete lame
peachy has spoken they're not getting
away with anything
somebody out there getting away with
something slick like they're doing
something out of the pocket
i have an important legal question lord
cognito if i say that i would rather
play the avengers beta than half the
mass effect series is that common oh
i think i'm on record for like 50
different podcasts now this is the
favorite topic of conversation with me
quiz me about mass effect 2 because the
lord incognito and twitter exchange we
had in like 2018.
yeah everywhere that it was stupid dale
this the uh the andromeda
oh this we're not gonna stop we're gonna
because this is gonna bring up old
emotions i'm trying to move forward i'm
trying to be able to be a three-hour
podcast it'll be a three-hour podcast
if microsoft buys wb uh most
level-headed xbox gamers would be happy
for those games to be multi-plat yeah
that's
i agree because we have game pass but
now
all right add it you've been waiting
patiently um seems like a lot of points
you want to get off that
this whole deal you know spider-man
exclusive where you're at man
well at the end of the day people want
to throw around
terms like anti-consumer i don't think
it's anti-consumer on sony's part this
is definitely all on square just like
huge has uh pointed out multiple times
i this when i when it comes to
exactly i don't think no one the biggest
thing i want to stress here
is no one should no one should
sign these kind of behaviors this kind
of practice
i i feel like the only way oh
are you speaking as i said
so so i think any gamer every gamer
should not want this type of practice to
go down
the only ones that i could even remotely
see
that want you know dlc particular i
think exclusives are different content
but
dlc for the same game that everyone pays
the only people that would want
this type of practice to continue is
people that's trying to cap for they
favorite plastic like there's no
amount of talking that anyone's going to
do to make me think that this stuff is
right
and it's not just you know square is on
some crazy stuff like
i would i'm not the biggest person on
boycotting stuff right you know
but when i saw this i saw that uh let me
go down real quick
if you're a verizon check back on monday
uh
verizon apparently has exclusive skins
if you're a horizon console really
and i'm just like wow i'm looking at 18
butterfingers right
i'm just sitting here looking at this
and i'm just like this game need a flock
because it's just like where are we
gonna call the line like
you know when it comes to destiny you
know clearly
the lords are a big fan of destiny this
particular game i didn't care because i
wasn't buying it
but i already got my i hate this stuff
through destiny 1.
you know and it happens wait till i go
me and you live
and you know what what's funny is people
didn't say nothing
yeah they wasn't they wasn't crying for
us
for us and it's like you know at the end
of the day i understand certain people's
scenarios but
in destiny you it was a year exclusivity
right
not only did sony do some grimy stuff
what
another thing sony did is they reached
back out to activations like
you know what i feel like with this has
been a really good relationship
and i think we're gonna extend the deal
of the stuff that we currently have
past destiny too so let me let me put
that in context for people in the chat
that's like a sequel coming out facts
and that's when you get to start that's
what you got
we got the d1 stuff with d2k
by the time you got the good stuff you
was already onto the new stuff
factual so it's just like you know it's
like i said
i think it's like anti-consumer on
square enix part sony's just doing what
sony does
just you know uh to bring more value to
the brand i can't really attack them for
that
but i do think regardless if i can
attack for them or not i don't think
anyone should condone this behavior i
think it should be frowned upon
everywhere
it's just it makes sense for somebody to
do but we shouldn't
be the we shouldn't be saying yeah this
is right you know this isn't right
it's just how they're going to do things
i guess and you know one final fantasy
what's funny squanish is the kind of
people
that they will make final fantasy 16
exclusive
and then when they finally release it on
the xbox platform they're going to
complain about the cells
and it's just like first off seven
remakes is exclusive
uh 16 is an exclusive like i'm starting
to think square might be in trouble over
there and they had to
be back here in rumblings we're hearing
rumblings about the next final fan as as
uh undead had brought out but well
that's what i said 16 exclusive i'm just
like
like that's one of the biggest issues i
have with a lot of people is like
you can't expect the jrpg
to grow as a brand on the xbox platform
when all of these games continue to be
behind
a wall that you have to wait for it
right fit enough
so oh sorry i'm going to get a super
chat then you will get off your god
conflicting points
with the five dollar super chat in five
years all these people contour warring
for
playstation are going to look crazy
while sony built the best boat microsoft
was inventing the jet engine
oh my god we got a two dollar superchat
from jd paper one
ring rule game pass
that's it we're done we're done all
right so it seems that you're on the
opposite side of the fence here you
agree with bg in a lot of his points so
let's get it man
uh us fan loving war we need the whole
land
this is war this is war and then what's
surprising to me
is that most of the when you look at the
history of gaming the companies that
have generally come out on top
generally for whatever reason the
following generation
decide to try to fix something that's
not broken and in the process they
stumble
um both sony and microsoft and even
nintendo have done
have done this this is one of the first
times that i see
sony exacting the exact same
uh game plan going into the following
generation
because honestly if the numbers are to
be believed they won three to one this
generation
three to one when you look at that and
you say how did we get there
right how did we get there well there's
there's a blueprint to that
and it feels like they're following that
same blueprint so
to me it's just it's one of those things
where when you look at
where they are in in the industry
they're the market leader
they have leverage that microsoft
doesn't have right
microsoft to have that leverage and mind
you like when you look at the 360
generation how did the 360 generation
get off to such a great start well
they came out a year earlier they were
up to 200 cheaper than
the opposition right and they deaded the
previous generation specifically early
so they could focus
on creating those relationships moving
forward correct and
going into you know the 360 generation
they had
call of duty 2 at launch they had all of
these exclusives at launch
not to mention that they didn't have
direct competition right
microsoft would have needed to do that
to be in this position where
even as the considerable loser
you know quote unquote loser in this
generation
they could have sort of they sort of
grown those relationships moving into
next gen right so the fact that a
they're playing two different games now
right game pass versus what sony's doing
is very different
so it's a it's it's it's a hard sell
right
you don't you that oh you're gonna sell
x amount of copies on xbox doesn't
resonate as much
as when a playstation person is talking
to you about it because that's
playstation's game that's their bag
um so i just think it's it's the it's
sony
realizing that their leverage a allows
them to
to do this and have third-party
publishers be receptive to this
um they they're going into next general
with the confidence that sony is going
to sell extremely well
on the other argument is it you know
would i prefer to see this all across
the board of course
of course right but it they're doing
exactly what got them to where they are
now
again and it's going to work again so
you know to bg's point play microsoft
you know like i said they're playing two
very different games
and at the end of the day the the rules
of the game are still
dictated by the one that that is the
perceived market leader
so microsoft could be doing what they
want to do and they could be doing great
at that
if they do not at any point ever show
that they can beat sony at their own
game
it's not going to matter all right let
me ask you a question cause you're on
fire with the chat is all fine
chad is like it is so funny to listen to
the chat because somebody's like yo i'm
sorry i'm spitting them bars right now
and then somebody's like yeah so let the
hustlers hustle let the hustlers hustle
you know what i'm saying so the sony
fans with you right now
it's lit but my question i'm gonna give
it to you guys i don't know king you
bubble i know
um the thing is that they've been
yelling time in my head for all these
dudes
you know so again like you know in
reference to
to that you know we definitely a lot of
people feel that way so you're i guess i
want to double down
like your thought process is that
microsoft
should engage in these kind of deals
themselves
in order to quote unquote compete
because the only reason why i ask you
that is because i remember
and i had this conversation with attic
when the square enix
rise of the tomb raider situation
happened and it was initially found out
that yo
this game is coming you know to xbox we
didn't know at the time but no there's
no mainstream playstations no mention of
another platform
so there was a big uproar and people
were like yo you know i'm saying how is
this this was an
established playstation franchise how is
it going xbox this is not fair you heard
the same kind of lingo
and consuming a lot of stuff so do you
think it's a situation that like
because of that negative reception
microsoft got it was very negative at
the time you know that that made them
shy away from doing these kind of deals
because we've seen their
position has pivoted they are on the
other side of everyone plays together we
don't want to feel it's kind of not into
the lock exclusive out deal
so what do you feel about that i mean
they're not stupid they saw the backlash
right so
whatever financial reasons they did it
for they saw the backlash and they
realized where they stand they you know
they can they can come out and market
you know and give us market spills to
death they know full well where they
stand
right in the in in the scope of gaming
they know full well where they stand and
they know
that there's going to be backlash to
anything they do to try to
make something that wasn't previously
exclusive exclusive right it's just the
reality of it so how
so you pivot the messaging and you make
it seem like it's anti-consumer
right on on every level and the thing is
and like hulk said as a general thing
yes it is because
you have this this one product is
essentially identical across all of
these platforms
but because of specifically what he said
because of how each one of these
characters is literally a character
class unto themselves yes like
you're eliminating an entire skill tree
you're like eliminating an entire
storyline arc from that game
on on all the other platforms so that
makes absolute sense right
but this isn't gonna be we're not gonna
we're not necessarily gonna see
this in this form
in the majority of deals that we're
going to see we're going to see petty
stuff like
maps we're going to see petty or smaller
i hate to
to warn yourself but i am hearing
rumblings
that this is just the beginning and
sony is adopting this strategy very
aggressively
for the playstation 5 um i believe the
gentleman named imran khan
um i think it was formerly a game
informer he was a gamer yeah
he made some interesting statements in
reference to this he basically was
saying that look
you know um he was all kind of funny i
believe he said look this is there is it
a major third party out there
sony has not failed to approach asking
what kind of deals they can work out
some had content some had games some had
content and
games he said it's not like microsoft
was not willing to offer
but they just didn't want to pay the
asking price because sony approached
with pretty high numbers in the first
place and he said
be on the lookout for a lot of
playstation
advantage branding console exclusive
wording so this is going to be the play
from what so they're is the play and
they're taking it to the next level now
right
right well like we said you know the
name of the video that lord cognito
introduced for me that i did virtually
gality was the problem with walled
gardens
yes and this is the business model for
selling a walled garden the difference
here
is that sony used to have another walled
garden next door
that was competing for these kinds of
things and one
kept everybody kind of equal and didn't
make one side or the other look
particularly bad
and two was maybe making the numbers
make more sense now sony's the only one
in the game
microsoft is as you correctly said
selling a completely different game and
one thing that is going to happen which
is the console warriors are going to
hate
is that i can promise you the
playstation 5 is going to sell five six
seven times
as much as the xbox series x microsoft
doesn't care
microsoft is looking at the profit
number they're selling a software
service
and they might make more money who knows
how this is gonna go that's where the
interest comes out of all this
but the console warriors the sony fans
they'll be able to point at the
difference in boxes
and that's not going to change for years
i object
to that statement
i object on the ground stating that the
tcl's
consumer only consumer and they are the
broke consumer and they're going to go
for the cheapest
four king goes let's get these super
chat circles
we got you got it yeah uh we got a
we're on the willow boat right on we got
we're on dizzy
dizzy okay i didn't know that okay all
right so we're on uh
here it is five dollar super chat from
dizzy the biggest thing as he has to
answer about
is how is this going to affect the
balancing in the future not
just a character but a whole class
itself
so i think he's telling like you know
taking that much content out of the game
it's definitely going to hurt
uh find out some chat from jd gamer
microsoft ought to teach sony a lesson
and show them how to money
halt for real hat for real 1.6 trillion
compared to 100 billion
uh sounds like a bad place to be for
sony
so he's saying that uh they they can
outbid them on everything if they wanted
to
we got a two dollar street shop from
philly eagle three to one hardware sales
not three to one in profits oh
for some reason we had a player yeah oh
philly does it matter though
yeah it does not really i'm not going to
know
listen if you work three times as hard
as me and i make the same amount of
money working half as you yeah it
matters
it matters a lot at the end of the day
if gaming in general engagement in
general is determined by
a market leader a market
i agree with the money i agree with the
money but at the end of the day
at the end of the day
[Laughter]
glad you said that i want the same
energy when the stream app pops on the
series
x the steam app oh god
like listen let's finish before you go
on another rant okay
we gotta find out
what is up have sound down but keep
blowing it up
i i guess the sound on it actually says
soft he agrees with you 100 percent he
only wrote that because fanboys like to
talk about sales
continue we caught up
my man trying to get his balls off right
now he he's frustrated
everybody tapping on this stupid game
that nobody wanted
not my avengers not too long ago it was
hashtag who wants this hashtag
it was it was all the time every time
you brought this game up y'all was like
why
and i was the only one sitting here like
it looked good when i saw it um
what's gonna call it at uh uh what is
that uh comic con
i was like i got a chance to see it i
was gonna um do an interview with the
dude but we couldn't record off the
thing
and i was like yo captain america stuff
looks good i said you know it looks like
something that
i can possibly think about but then i
got on this whole stance that i'm not
paying for no games so i i feel exactly
what what we would do because if you
have the most underpowered system going
into the next generation you're going to
try to dress that pig up and put
on it anyway you trying it doesn't
matter you're going to try to make that
pig look pretty
i feel you you put that lipstick on that
pig and you get her out there you make
sure
are you implying that because they have
them
right it's a pig because at the same
time you guys out here really
this is crazy i see you guys like you're
some foregone conclusion that the fight
is almost over like the fight is done
so mike tyson thought the same way when
he was going up against buster douglas
we all know how to end it bro
acting like oh they did the same thing
before they said he knew when the stream
strategy
so they're going into the same stretch
every time you do the same thing
you don't evolve and you don't change
you get busted wide
they're about to get busted wide open
because when you spend all your
money buying exclusive content for a
dead system
you will understand at the end of the
day oh sweat they switched this they
just said it's a different system
king is your position that the series x
will outsell the playstation 5.
oh the world is going to break your
knees in
a lock heart any day just so
just sort of clarify you're saying that
with the combination of the law card and
the series x it's going to overwhelm the
ps5
it's over
[Applause]
they're going to definitely go with a
cheap system they don't got to upgrade
their tcl
they can get a lot out of one so so
christopher heart
he says he wants your knees anything
you're the only one purchasing that that
playstation five on day one
because it ain't working here for you to
purchase we just saw the state of play
it was amazing i'm used by this
this is nothing to continue when you say
i deal with this weekly hole
get them killed
yo they had nothing so why not go buy
everything right okay
yeah i don't think sony has anything to
show that's very exciting right now what
in the world do you think microsoft has
to show that's exciting
i can tell you this whole as a lawyer
you know there's always somebody
penny-pinching you right
always trying to a better deal right
i've occasionally taken muffins for
legal work
sony is the muffin dude
[Music]
i'm not impressed with either side's
marketing and messaging right now but i
do think
i you know i think it's a faticom plea
that the playstation 5 is gonna have
something like 60 70 percent of the
console sales in the next generation
okay so at the same time i want your
knees on deck
so we're doing to bend the knees
jump up i don't want to hit objection
i don't hit nothing now when that
lockhart jump up and they got to pay
and you're going to see the cheap dude
spend i mean
you do spend like no other like delivery
think at any point in time it's it's
about oh what they got exclusive they
got spider the chief dude don't care
about spider-man over there
you don't really care at all all he all
he cares about is if he can play madden
2k and everything else on his system
okay all right television let's let's
get these terms
is this a rope in the knee or are we
just like fake bending the knee right
now
he's sitting there acting like it's all
right so so what's the conditions of the
bend the knee
this is this that anything the microsoft
platform is deep
see hold yourself into one little
platform that playstation 5.
microsoft has definitely extended itself
all over the place
so when they spread their self out like
that you can lose anywhere you want to
go
you know now that lockhart is going to
be the primary seller they're going to
be pushing that into
everybody's home why haven't they
announced it yet
okay so they're holding out lockhart's
gonna launch close to the series x
and they're using it as a silver bullet
in their gun that's that's the thesis
that's that that's his thesis
all right so you call it the pincer
attack
just that curiosity king i got to get
you know everything in line are we
saying that
xbox is going to beat them in unit cells
or financial cells smoke them all around
the board
don't let king get away being vague
don't do that
so you speaking from a place of
experience
i learned this years ago do not let him
be vague
like this one part right here and you
got to be detailed because you throw
some gay pass clause in there
everybody's laughing right
everybody's laughing and the dave
spider-man comes out on the playstation
4
it ain't gonna be fine did they come out
he's gonna come out of game pass to get
him savage
they were like yay spider-man came out
and game pass dudes like finally
listen i need your position on
exclusively they will catch the super
chat just what's your position on okay
i think i think sony needs to do
whatever they can do to win
i don't care how you do it i really love
the fact
when you play dirty in the next war
however you wanna do it like listen
they play dirty enough to tell you that
you can only play miles morales over
here when we know it's a dlc
i totally agree i think it was a dlc
that got expanded out and they're using
it to try to sell it is the only thing
they have at launch
oh are you waiting hulk are you implying
that the launch ladder
is is weak and that they need to do
these sort of things to
to get garner interest in the
playstation look i'm implying that
neither side is ready for coveted
reasons or otherwise
i don't know they need to launch these
consoles because they need them for
their financials and it's clear that the
launch lineups are not even as
swiss cheese as usual they have more
holes than cheese
i i think that's the reason we haven't
seen release dates in a lot of these
games and i think that's one of the
reasons they haven't showed
a real estate for the console because
they don't know what games are going to
show up at day one
no they don't need ducks in order again
i
appreciate that sony is even working in
one arena i mean if okay
your your specs is set right so you
can't go in there and boost it any
further it's already boosted
right yeah no it's overclocked yeah so
you can't boost it anymore it's already
juggling trying to do things
so at the same time we know that it's
gonna take some time for games to show
up while the games are showing up let's
sign these exclusive deals let's do this
stuff
put name money in other phil told you
we're not doing that no more yeah we're
not running out there chasing these
dudes trying to buy these games and it
leads to a dead end
yeah because at the end of the day when
those deals run out either are you going
to up those deal
or then you're on even playing field
with the competitor
that details ran out so it leads to a
relationship that was like on hold like
like it doesn't work right i feel that
they should have used that money
because those games is going to come
anyway right use that money
to to either open up more studios or
or research other things stuff that's
more gaming related but if
if that's not an option
get spider-man lock it to your system do
whatever you got to do to make sure that
you win
because at it you know they definitely
are king they definitely are
oh what what i what i don't like is
because i have a lot of these d
i i had a whole little rant thing ready
but we got the time stuff
i don't like people running around with
fake narratives like they got this
insider information oh i'mma tell you
next generation has locked down
many deals i can't say right now
inside my you see my dm's you get a lot
of information yeah
i had stuff inside my dms your god of
war gonna be shown
this stuff gonna be done listen just
leave me alone with all the speculation
talk leave me alone with all these
what you want to happen um tyson wanted
to win that night he fought buster
douglas
just had to carry on hanging over his
head i hate to interrupt you i just want
to ask a quick question
don't you speculate with stuff like
cyberpunk going in again
listen listen i bet you i bet your knees
on it right
i bet your knees on it but but you you
speculate you you made that bet because
you're the speculation that you know
what's going on is the difference
between somebody running around saying
something is fact
and me saying yo the tea leaves is
lining up for those dudes to go on game
pass
and i'm gonna get my chips on black so
that's me
me i'm not saying i got a sauce telling
me i'm not telling you i heard it from
my
i get you when you say that that's
me coming up with something that i've
seen i'm like wow he's just like look
it's going to happen
he's not saying he's not saying you know
what king i heard all kinds of stuff you
know they got all these exclusives that
you know sony's outbidding everyone
they all fitting everything we gotta get
these super chats we gotta get these
super chats
i'll let you make your money playstation
five will sell more than lockhart pick
your date king
oh more than lockhart okay um
uh march of next year oh next year
okay so that's when the fifth school is
up right
um uh yeah i their musical will be done
march 31st
one of them might have a june 30. mm-hmm
okay would you like to stay home
we'll say the physical report is that
okay all right i'm talking about
so let's say let's say march 31st let's
call it march 31st
sure all right ps5 beating the brakes
off of them oh
okay hold on hold on are we saying the
log car and the the series x
just the whole part so we're just saying
the lock the lock call cause
come on you got to put the series x
numbers i got faith you about to lose
the knees
listen listen i know i know right now
in this room i know in this room
alone you know what he's being too
you are literally saying they don't need
the series
though you know that xbox doesn't report
numbers right so how are we getting
[Laughter]
wow that was classic king all right
you you what are you a side lawyer too
i learned this game a long time listen
the moment the moment lord ken
had to crawl through your oh my god onto
you
that was it that was it we can't we
never could lose the kick again no you
cannot lose a king ever in the game
yo what do you call your lawyer
apprentice what what are they called
again
would they call home understand what
they call no
associates they did they i don't think
they got a
a a a law degree yet or whatever they
what
apparel not apparently not illegal yeah
trying to be a paralegal behind put down
and be
all right we have a fork boy with the
five dollar super chat what is up have
sound down but keep blowing it up okay i
guess
i guess we're blowing out his eardrums
or something he's streaming then we have
viper with the uh 5
super chat i think sony will again lead
the way in console sales but microsoft
will take off when it comes to
subscribers in the ecosystem
they're already winning with the
subscribers in the ecosystem that's for
sure
then we have fork boy again with the 10
sweep chat i have my i have
my sound down i wanted to drop in to say
hello
i'll have to watch it later thank you
thank you all for what you do and keep
it up
what's going on getting behind the box
that's what's up um what else
we gotta find out superstar regulator
price matters less than 25 percent of
gamers play their first party games
the common gamer usually goes towards
the cheaper console
king i got you so you're with you
brother
oh you know people people go not that
obviously we ain't gonna know what they
sold but we ain't talking last time
we got a two dollar super chat for
regulator with xcloud
xbox will have a bigger user base yeah i
don't think there's a whole lot
to say against that okay you you read
this uh song
which one from hope from cat daddy five
dollars super chat
come on hold your lawyer you live on the
particular don't let him be vague
permission to treat him like a hostile
witness
then we have drunken ninja with the 5
super chat we back baby finally made a
live show shout out to iop
film when he packs spencer is the truth
we have luke lord the insipid ghost with
the two dollar super chat
get them bars off new official slogan of
iop
facts of what's here besides that we we
definitely need a um
are you implying emoji we need that oh
yeah they they like what i do
we have viper xt with the 5 super chat
my household will have one series x
three lock hearts versus one playstation
five
so that's already four to one ratio to
start
thank you for the antidote right yeah
i'm not you're not exactly what i would
call um uh
objective
chat if you have a tcl you are not
buying ps5
you are messy y'all man shout out to
screen man like i'll make it quick
because we're going super long with this
man we
got to move on look all i say alex said
it best for me man
welcome to my world spidey fans welcome
man
because as a destiny fan i know what
you're going through
because it was destiny no one came don't
one kid know what shout out to
look man i get it do i really care i
mean probably
not but i understand what you guys are
saying you know from
does it feel good what's the optics what
is it you know it doesn't necessarily
feel good when
strikes and character and the whole
skill tree is taking out the game but
you know look
you gotta look at where the money went
you know the money went square took the
bag
it is what it is you know as far as the
you know the competing thing
you know i get it but it's just seeing
microsoft doesn't want to make those
kind of deals anymore they've been very
explicit that's not where they're going
there has been a pivot as far as their
thought process you know as far as um
exclusivity stuff and exclusive content
and um
that's pretty much it the only thing i
will empathize and undead said this well
you know it
when it's when it's a multi-plat i don't
have a problem if you if you if you
buy the game if you buy the game and you
make it exclusive to your platform i
really don't have a problem
i actually prefer that but i think where
i struggle with
like it's it's a multi-platform game
that contents being removed out
right so this these other groups don't
have it and i get it you know the guys
on the winning team they like yo we got
it you should buy our system anyway i
feel you i get that
i'm just saying that the other side they
just don't feel good right so
to me the only devs that did it right
was namco because i remember if y'all
remember king remember
soul calibur 2 like the xbox fans had
spawn gamecube had link you know what
i'm saying
and playstation so this way if you're
going to do this exclusive joint
then give people multiple copies of that
game right
so to me smart to the developer if if
they did it that way
yeah but what i've heard also it's not
it's not just spider-man
right oh yeah it gets very stinky and
nasty
every character announced yeah it's
launched on the playstation 4
first yeah but i don't know i don't know
that's
in reference to that and references no
they used a hawkeye actually as a
defensive
like perry when they were getting all
this spider-man stuff so it would very
much surprise me if there's a deal on
you know that their war table had
essentially a hawkeye symbol and three
question marks i think they're set up
for
multi-platform support of what were
those original like four editions
yeah do you think they're gonna give
the xbox additional character or just
just like run with the spider-man and
just dead i truthfully don't think
microsoft is in the business of buying
exclusivity right now i i really do
think
you know i think you framed it as
messaging and that might be to some
extent true you don't want to look like
you're you're losing on a head-to-head
but i really do think that the games as
a service model the the recurring
revenue
software sales model doesn't demand this
kind of marketing expenditure
um so i really do think they're out of
that game and if you look at
it like right now they're about game
pass that's the highlight of everything
and buying timed exclusives behind a
game that's not coming day one and game
pass would be against that too
so yeah absolutely and like i said hulk
put up put a ribbon on it
at the end of the day like i said do i
like it no i'm not but for me again i'm
selfish
i got everything so i'm not gonna miss
out on no experience
you know what i'm saying if it would if
it hit me emotionally because i i don't
shout out to kybatsu like he's a big
spider-man fan he prefers
and it hit him hard it hit him hard he
was just like damn like i really
you know i'm saying i gotta get it over
you know i'm saying like he really
didn't want to do that and i feel i
don't
i guess for me the equivalent hogue
would be like silver surfer or something
i'm a surfer fanboy so if that happened
then i'm like damn but
again i got playstation i got xbox i got
switch i got pc
i ain't missing out if my man is
somewhere well spider-man such an
interesting one because he really
is especially before the mcu yeah
marvel's crown jewel
yes yeah and so it's it's that that was
a heavyweight
punch and yeah you know i wish it wasn't
that way the only other thing i would
say to the panel and i know obviously
we're running along
uh is um there were a couple people that
said it's not sony's fault
and and i will say this in order for
somebody to take the bag there has to be
a bag man
and there is a certain responsibility
there and to say you know what i would
prefer it if they weren't
um i think we'd bet we'd have a better
stronger industry with more money spent
on developing things that we love
i have one question for hope yeah do you
think
is positioning their console as this
the the premier place to play spiderman
the only place
to play spider-man because with the
mouse and
they're associated with the original
spider-man game and now this
also with spider-man and the fact that
sony movies with spider-man
and you have venom coming out with
morbius and stuff
do you believe that well i think there's
value to them there right so when you're
looking at
how much to spend on something like what
we saw with the crystal dynamics
avengers game
uh the sony pictures arm of the company
can say hey you know that's a nice
marketing spend for us
keeping spider-man in the zeitgeist
keeping him culturally
uh important again assuming that
avengers crystal dynamics takes some
amount
of cultural cachet than the the
marketing folks at sony it's an easier
it's easier to say this is just like
buying a 100 commercials on espn
and so it makes a lot more sense and
then i think sony feels that
that continues to pay dividends in kind
of a multiplicative way
right that it hits pictures it hits
their insomniac product i mean
spider-man 2
is going to happen uh in probably you
know 2022.
so so this is also spending more money
to get that
folks ready for that as well and i
really do think regardless of what the
crystal dynamics blog post says
that there will be light there will be
light connective tissue with insomniac
spiderman yeah
and plus i think that when it comes down
to it the biggest
obviously sony wants exclusive content
on their platform but i think the
biggest reason they're doing this is
because they want that
that that link between their brand and
spider-man's brand yeah because they do
span as a good it's a good will that
they didn't build that is still kind of
associated with sony a little bit
and why not take advantage of that yeah
because i mean when you see the new
avengers start popping off the new
spider-man start popping off
you know they want to be the only person
in the block that we got the spider-man
games no one else got that
right and at the end of the day look at
the other day even though i don't
personally care for these deals you know
what i'm saying
they keep doing them for a reason so at
the end of the day you don't say it's up
to the gamers right
the problem is gamers get mad but they
actually don't revoke what they wallet
and stop the practices they they
end up bending the knee and still doing
it or buying it or whatever whatever and
that's
what's up a second yeah so no no i think
this is fair there are people that are
going to be more passionate about this
and people that are going to be less
passionate about this but the market is
the market
so people do vote for their wallet on
things that some of us
all agree with and some things that they
don't you look at things like
ea's loot box extravaganza 2018
and the sales in things like battlefront
and in need for speed
it changed their entire philosophy right
because of how strong the rejection of
that practice was
i do think that there is a danger online
to say people don't vote with their
wallet
when it doesn't go the direction i
personally as an individual would have
it go
i understand what you're saying with
that all i'm saying is in reference to
these specific
practices these specific practices i've
seen it you know
i've seen it with destiny i've seen it
where the entire
exotics and hawkmoon and all this stuff
i've seen it where it's completely
removed from the game
and what i this is my personal feeling
i feel the the fans of the lead platform
who are getting these deals that favor
them you know i'm saying it's fine
right it's fine like i i feel like it
hasn't reached a point
i think this was the first time i was
i'll give you this hulk this is the
first time i've seen
media outlets kind of look at sony
sideways even though
we're not blaming sonia for all this but
you know look at this and say nah this
is not a good look
right yeah but prior to that the
these deals have been going on for a
long time this is the way the business
was run
absolutely the difference is that
microsoft backed down right and that's
really fundamentally the psychological
difference right here i don't
i'm not suggesting it's otherwise right
sony has always done this microsoft had
always done this
the difference is that microsoft said
nah we'd like to be open to everybody
and now that makes sony retroactively
look like what they've done always
is a lot worse than it otherwise was
yeah yeah yeah and
combined with the controller thing going
on right it was the same day yeah it was
the same day right so it was like a
perfect storm you're absolutely right
i'll give you that
it was a perfect storm again at the end
of the day like i said people
i would like to see if if it's this
strong
what these avengers numbers do or
whatever whatever and then we'll we'll
make it determining factor
whether or not gamers actually avengers
is going to sell well regardless of what
the panel says
at the end of the day i think when it's
when it's something that has
directly to do with with something
monetary like
loot boxes i think people people
sort of stand on their square longer and
they will vote with their wallets
when it comes to content people will get
over it eventually that's what i feel
that's what i feel so get over it yup
get over it it's going to be
business as usual and nobody that's how
i feel with this but
until i'm proven wrong maybe this is the
the turning point
but i need to see it where it it really
hit
the marvel avengers sales and people
just tired of this
you know i need to see it because i
don't believe it just yet so anyway i'm
going on too long
we got a lot of stuff going on um we
will speedball these last two days these
are pretty
short and get the superchat sir yeah we
got a few we have uh michael aka bet
size finance with two dollars super chat
lockhart takes the w
shootout uh lord king yeah so he feels
that lockhart will
win fight for xt with the five dollar
chat my three kids only play roblox
minecraft and fortnite that's why i will
have three lockhearts roblox
not available on hold on i playstations
jumped give me a second i gotta jump
okay
and we have uh lord farms around the
game with the five dollar super chat
talk to the gamers on the street they
all want the ps5
mind [ __ ] it just is what it is
to all the gamers on the street but
financially the game is on the street
ain't got that bread so they
they're gonna pull me up for that
lockhart they could want whatever they
want i want a lamborghini
i'm playing a camaro good luck we got
michael askew with the two dollar super
cat
ps5 is running on our dna one gpu
wait for the long time oh my god a spike
by
come on man shout out to mike
you don't say it but look we got to move
on man we'll make these quicks i know
hogue's time
is limited i don't want to over outwell
them too yeah i got a hard stop at 3 30.
so
okay cool cool so we got okay thank you
for that man so we'll move on um look
this is like king's talk topic i'll
frame it real quick for him
look microsoft and um samsung man they
look like they have a special
partnership going on with um xbox game
pass
and android samsung is unveiling its new
uh note 20 handset with uh with a unique
xbox game pass partnership
and it says microsoft is parking
partnering with samsung include a
special version of the game pass app
in the galaxy store and then we got a
little bit of extra details on it along
with the game pass app samsung has
offered a gaming bundle
for the note 20 that includes three
months of game pass ultimate and
power a's um x plus much like some type
of peripheral
to you know to to play with it to doing
the x cloud thing the controls made with
the game streaming x cloud part of the
ultimate and the last part of this
partnership is that it builds on
this uh initial deal that the two
companies first revealed last year
and they look to partner to bring
android and windows closer together
so yeah this is a partnership that went
down i know king i'm gonna let you go
this is
this was your topic you know in
reference to the whole situation so
where are you at with this man well um
when we initially heard that microsoft
and uh samsung had uh got into a
partnership deal
i didn't think that it was too far you
know like crazy because uh anytime you
saw an xbox one you saw samsung
televisions
and they kind of geared their stuff up
in line with uh
xbox stuff like the 2.1 uh 120 refresh
rate that which is available right now
like you can get 120 frames
on your regular xbox one x right now and
the xbox s
um that stuff is built in their
functionality but what i've noticed is
that this has extended to all their
future devices because i tuned in to
watch what samsung was bringing to the
forefront right
because i'm a android user yes so i was
uh checking to see what new phones it
was coming out and then when they had
phil come on i'm like what the hell is
going on
and he was like he's happy that they
partnered with them and then they showed
the bundle
and they showed the functionality of it
now they broke it down now
i remember if somebody said something in
july that in august
that they will be they would have uh
something talking about
xcloud and the functionality of it and
this is when you have uh
fake information fake sources in the
background it was
this show they were talking about xcloud
and the functionality of it and the ease
of it and how it was going to work and
the apps that would be
on the tvs uh of windows devices samsung
devices all across the boards
and this further extends their reach
this
is why i don't think you know the whole
deals with them making
uh with uh developers were on the table
or even an
option to be honest with you because
they're trying to strengthen game pass
so uh strengthening game pass and
putting it in the samsung store
and having more than what is it like two
billion people or cell phone people
um is is that the strategy to win is
this the winning combination
got you if this is the long play let's
get home and then we'll get
as far as the you know the play here
well what are you feeling about this
partnership hulk
with samsung on the kind of stuff you
know i the thing that i've followed on
my social media has really been the
attacks that happened against apple
across all of these various companies
which seems to be a
uh how would i you know certainly not an
anti-trust violation
uh it seems to be a concerted action oh
no that's in the sherman act too
well you know what it appears to be
companies that both decided or multiples
of them decided that they would now
attack apple and so
it's one of those things that i think is
different than the spider-man
conversation and i think is different
than really anything else going on
is this kind of tech interface and if i
were to
guess i would say that there are
companies talking about whether or not
they want to try to bring in action or
encourage the doj to bring an action
against apple i think that's the
underlying story
with all the samsung and android stuff
fair enough
enough undead man where are you at with
this samsung
and uh microsoft partnership i i guess
it's cool i'm
just the whole x cloud mobile thing just
i have zero interest and unfortunately i
just
uh i traded out my like samsung s2 i've
had for like
many years and i got upgrade to a work
phone and it's an iphone 10
so i'm not going to be using the xcloud
anytime yeah you definitely could use a
nice cloud
but no i think it's interesting how
they're partnering their cloud
partnership
in terms of like cloud partnerships this
makes a whole lot of sense
yeah um and we have the whole
conversation about walled gardens
if there is still a walled garden that
has not been
lowered at any point it's apple yes
and uh people are starting the apple
consumer base is starting to ask
questions about that
and i think that's that's cool for
people to use apple procs because i
always kind of
gave my head a shake with some decisions
apple makes but like like everything
everyone has a preference what they want
to use ease of use and
everything else but uh the samsung
microsoft thing it just
it makes sense yeah did you see the
facebook comments
undead in reference to them as well
being upset
with uh with apple uh everybody's upset
about everything
um everybody like
let me put this way if apple starts
lowering some of their very
very like old school way of thinking of
what they allow
in their tech app store and some of some
of their policies that people are
starting to take issue with
it'll be cool to see a more free and
open apple because
literally the price just keeps going up
on these phones and i just keep looking
at them and going
what are you getting from that yeah and
that's just where i'm at with apple and
samsung like i don't have a phone
preference it's like my work gives me a
phone
i don't have to pay for it that's my
phone cool i don't care
um but i think microsoft partnering with
samsung makes a whole lot of sense
and i think like the whole where they're
bundling a controller and they're
bundling game pass
into it and everything else it makes a
boatload of sense in terms of what their
end game goals are
no doubt no doubt lord addict what are
we feeling about this partnership sir
your beauty oh sorry sorry about that uh
i think it's smart i particularly don't
care about the streaming thing but um
i do know that one of the biggest
markets that they can't get into is
stuff like japan
uh china and i think this is why those
are designed obviously they're gonna get
a western
audience but i think the main reason
they made this is because okay we can't
we can't get in these markets with an
xbox they don't
play consoles like that they play the
switch uh we can compete with the switch
but not on a big
grand scale like that but we're able to
at least get in their homes
right fair enough fit enough lord assaf
what do we feel about this sir uh let's
get these super chats real quick yeah
elemental view 5 super chat let's be
real this dlc is not being made by sony
or insomniac sony may have overpaid for
under average content yeah
that's true i'll say that he loves that
event regulator with the two dollar
super chat
uh goodbye to my iphone and hello to my
note 20 ultra
woo 300
uh yeah so uh my feeling on this i'm
kind of
in agreement with hogue i i think it's
less we're used to seeing
all of these sort of deals through the
lens of of gaming right
but i think as a whole i think the deal
is more important to
like the confluence of these two big
platforms being like the computer
platform by the pc platform
and android basically the two big
platforms finding a way to have this
connection
and again in a way sort of
maybe trying to form this connection to
try to shame
uh apple into dropping the wall garden
right
um much like you know what happened with
fortnite like playstation and stuff like
that like
find a way to to to form devastator in
such a way that apple has to bend the
knee
yeah um so i i see that is bigger and
then
and obviously you know what microsoft's
connection was like
the pc in there they're sort of like uh
their productivity apps and stuff like
that i think it makes more sense
i honestly the game pass stuff to me i
just feel like game pass
is more successful on a platform if you
like obviously like
the apple store if that would ever
happen or google play or something like
that
samsung creating their own specific
platform and having
you know game pass specific stuff on
there it's just it's again it's like
having another launcher
it feels like it makes it more difficult
to just hear horns i'm sorry to
interrupt you jonathan wilson welcome to
the realm put the horns in the chat for
john the one
welcome to the realm continue yeah so i
think i i think on that end
i mean it's great to have game pass in
one more place
i don't know if it moves the needle as
much as
as as this being a move to try to make
apple sort of change their thinking on
these things
yeah fair enough fair enough i'll jump
in um yeah man i i feel i kind of agree
with addict i think it's like it's the
long play
you know um as far as um x cloud
and game pass you know i think they
they're trying to sneak their way on
everything except apple obviously
outside having that
but um look it's great to link with one
of the biggest tv brands and phones i
mean
people don't realize like galaxy is huge
and the samsung ground is huge in korea
and south asia
and um i think this is a market that
they want to penetrate you know this is
markets that are historically are never
going to buy an xbox console i think
they're really investing
in this ecosystem i think for me king
what i need
is samsung on the q led game and i think
it's coming
they need that game pass app as part of
that smart tv suite
isn't it on atvs i don't know i've had
i've had a samsung in a while
but um yeah i think because i that to me
is cool on a hardware level that you're
just bringing your controller
you have the already the the visual
device and then
with the technology that the series x
has which we we discussed as far as the
lower latency
and automatically switching it into a
game mode you know to then
link into an s cloud i think that could
be something that they're looking to do
so
yeah yeah the the thing about that
because i had that same question did
they have
announced any specific tv integration
and the problem with that is that it's
like
well the person who's buying that
highlight that that high-end samsung tv
is probably having a physical box you
know on
it's there aren't necessarily going to
be swayed by the x-cloud argument right
they probably have a physical box
uh or pc you know under their tv so it's
like
that that sort of venn diagram of where
that where
where the person that that that's for
actually fits right it's kind of
small so i don't know like the tv thing
because i know so many times
assumption though that's an assumption
made uh
based off of your demographics because
you have uh the high-end consumer
which is anyone to be honest with you it
can just be a pc gamer
you know and uh he happens to just look
in the app store and say oh sweat what's
that
you know and oh there's an xbox in there
that i don't even have to buy i could
just play the games right here
so i really think that that that's that
that really doesn't um really extend
there because
you put it there for anybody that
chooses to actually use it at any point
in time you you can't
just pigeonhole the thought in all this
high-end television
only people with consoles is going to
buy this anyway i i don't believe that's
right i don't know look
it's it's an interesting yeah it's all
about you no no i just
i i get that right but it just it just
feels like
i don't know like if so a lot of i know
people people that have money
that don't care about they don't
necessarily follow
what's the newest and best in tech right
so yeah you would
like not like us like us we follow that
stuff right on top of it
there's other people that just they'll
how much that tv call
is ten thousand that one's fifteen okay
give me the fifteen thousand dollar one
right and it's like
yeah and it just that just matters to
them i understand but that doesn't mean
it's imperative for microsoft to
do these kind of marketing deals where
they're bringing awareness to the fact
that their service is on
these devices and to be aware of it
right
i think it's it's a matter of yeah
putting the messaging out there not just
putting it on the platform and then just
saying anything about that right i think
i think on the ces show
next year when the new uh tvs are being
rolled out the milli
mini leds and stuff like that uh i think
then you will see those type of things
there with those uh
because i they did have with the last
samsung
they hdmi 2.1 and they did have an xbox
uh x1x right there with the guy given
the demonstration
on it uh sean because it was the only
console at the time that can actually do
it so
um yeah so yeah i believe they're doing
it my last point was just that um
you know for me personally the i the
razer key she that really excited me
because that literally made
my phone my android look like a nintendo
switch shout out to brad sams he has a
great review on it it sold me on the
device
i went to the microsoft store it was
sold out okay oh you pre-ordered yours
right
pre-ordered my kishi but i had to go to
amazon to get it so that's pretty much
it man we'll see how this thing plays
out this is definitely the play that
they are going with
but it is 3 30 we got to give a hard
stop to lord
hogue who rocked with us the whole
business law firm very spicy takes we
saved him from an
inevitable possible kid
but thanks to the paralegal that is
solved
hey i'm all for it
my bill is going to be in the email
hopefully i'm sure
i mean i can charge for this too
oh pay him the muffins
we got whatever we got to get hold out
of here man he has rock with us man
much love lord hold where can the five
people find you
what you got going on sir yeah
absolutely like we referenced a couple
times in this podcast i have a series on
youtube called virtual legality that
talks about things like this business
and law
through the prisms that uh we're already
reading about um
media movies tv and of course video
games
so we talk about these kinds of things
through interesting stories like
when sony and the disney folks fought
about whether spider-man would be in
their movies or not or now
whether spider-man should appear on
microsoft's xbox series actor lockhart
or where have you
so we do that a lot we have a lot of fun
in it as i said at the top of this show
in a surprise to me we're about now
let's see after this show let's
let's check what's the numbers we're
about 40 subscribers away from 20
000. so if you want to uh if you want to
come on in and help get us over the hump
uh right now i would certainly
appreciate it and we think we have a lot
of fun
in that space otherwise folks can find
me there uh at hoglaw on youtube as well
as at hoglaw on twitter where
i'm taking more and more dms now we're
regarding things like spider-man and
things like trump executive orders it
really cuts both ways in my case
so please feel free to reach out to me
there and subscribe to the channel and
otherwise i look forward to the next
time oh you don't know
what i'm doing here lauren oh you know
brother we got to get you back on man
always a pleasure to be a police officer
on youtube he is phenomenal just just to
see his growth i'm super proud of him
always glad to call my friend to the
realm man continue on your journey
brother you know we bringing you back we
we go
we're going to recap again when the
ghost is seeming great with the year
stuff come back
we go cherry blossom up well enjoying
that once
i'm right where you are you said mid act
two that's right where i am oh okay cool
so we go we go
we go polly once we go finish the game
absolutely brother always a pleasure man
have a good all right talk to you guys
later thanks for having me
all right undead i know i got you
hostage or this last time i don't let me
know your time is because we're going to
roll out quick
like i i got to make 15 minutes
for rolling pins
man let's rock this out man last joint
this is lord addict his topic man
launch launch launch what's going on
i'll give you permission to
to roll it out because uh because i'm
eating no no it's pizza time
so um look man lord addict had brought
this to my attention it's a fun topic
you know we we've got these next-gen
consoles coming out
and the question is you know launch
lineups right and um
we've got series x we get an idea kind
of what
series x is doing getting the idea kind
of playstation 5 we still have
definitives yet
but you know for anything that is coming
out in 2020 and stuff like that when
these systems launch at the end of the
year we kind of want to get an idea i
guess
what is exciting you so um
attic i don't know if you want to set it
off i'll just give it to undead
however you want to spark it off undead
okay so again what are you feeling man
with these launch lines like uh which
one are you more excited about are you
not excited about either way yeah
okay so i did a piece on microsoft and
sony and their constant game of chicken
um that they're doing with prices and
everything else which is what's the
gaming annoying
um self plug that but the also thing
that's super annoying with all this
is we don't want to talk about prices
and we don't want to talk about dates
we don't want to talk about dates of
these launch lineups all we get is these
holiday 2020 launch windows
uh no one wants to go into detail about
because like basically if you go to a
list of confirmed launch games right now
for your launch launch window games as
you've got
miles miles more morales for playstation
you've got death loop
and i think bug snacks is also in there
i know the meme at this point but
it's it's there it's there it's
available
um and xbox we've got halo infinite
and there's something else but it's
slipping my mind
um that's it [ __ ] i think medium
medium medium thank you it may be
scoring i don't know
yeah yeah so we're looking at these
and these are our launch lineups we got
our third party because obviously these
consoles are going to fall somewhere
between
the first week of november and the end
of november because cyberpunk
assassin's creed are like two days apart
so obviously there's something going on
there
um and then watchdogs legions october
29th
just before um these launch lineups i
i don't know i think these launch
lineups pre-covered were going to be
pretty great
because i in my gut feeling i feel like
ratchet and clank and demon souls were
going to be part of the playstation 5
launch lineup
i really do feel that but i don't think
they will be now i'm thinking this will
be spring
2021 games um all these people i see
running with rumors and creating
fabricated rumors
about halo infinite not making launch oh
crazy
oh oh was this okay spicy
um also wrote an article stop believing
every 4chan rumor you read
go read that and learn yourself some
stuff um
because if halo infinite doesn't launch
this holiday the series x won't launch
this holiday
so stop with the nonsense it's the same
thing with the playstation camp there's
going to be more than just spider-man
there
um covid really screwed up these launch
lineups and i'm
legitimately i'm looking at it and i
kind of
wish i know as hoax said financially
these companies aren't going to do that
but as a gamer i would be okay
for them delaying these consoles into
quarter ones so we can have
more software more appealing software to
kind of showcase these games because
like
i don't really want to do the whole
playstation 4 and xbox one thing of
buy a couple of games at launch and then
wait a year and a half for the good
stuff to come out and i kind of feel
like that's where we're at right now
okay let me jump in ahead of turn
because this was all i
had to get my mind thinking on this
topic look it was interesting obviously
i'm a guy that always buys
both regardless day one the whole deal
you know i can't front i had this
conversation with king
after the state of play i gotta be
honest you know what i'm saying unless
there's a few
more announcements that like our dad is
saying that we don't know about just yet
i want that pumped i got the vf5 lords
letter and
i know miles is there and miles is going
to hit it's going to do what it do but
you know as i've said before and the
studio said themselves what is it like i
don't know 8 to 10 hour
kind of expansion deal did you buy the
regular spider-man yeah i have a regular
one
so it's like furniture no i've not
finished it i'm at the third quarter
so it's like one of those games it's
like yeah it's cool i'm not
spider-man hardcore like that but it was
fun i recognized it's a good game but
again i will get it but it's not again
it's for me
it's the selfish gamer right it's what
is getting me to go by
right so the game that i thought was
going to be it for me
was godfall and then i saw it and then i
forgot i forgot about godfall yeah and
then i saw it and i'm just like okay
again this is my
opinion y'all this is not i'm nasty i'm
talking about selfishly cognito as a
game of what appeals to me
that's what i'm talking about so that
was the joint that i thought was going
to be like luna shooter slasher
and then the gameplay loop and i'm like
i don't know
you know it'd be a game i pick up but
again
what is th like if ratchety clank was
there they say that's there
bam you know what i'm saying you know
what i'm saying i'm okay you got me
that's something i'm very interested in
i want to see how that ssd do
right i want to see all that stuff but
um yeah man so
that was that and then like i'm just now
that'll be hearing this whole rumor
of you know them purchasing um exclusive
games possibly
and to get into their camp i kind of
want to see if any of those type of
games fall into that list and make
launch
because then i'll be excited okay they
got this game that was
primarily multi-platform before and now
it's exclusive
now i like that game and then boom you
know what i'm saying i'm in
but i gotta be honest y'all like craig
face and all i'm still hype about halo
infinite man like i
i'm a halo guy i like that so my thing
is i like the gameplay loop i like
the grappling hook i like multiplayer i
like carrying 120 frames i like hearing
free to play
you know what i'm saying but it's not
just that like for me you got that
i'm you know i like the yakuza series i
like that new one that new one is
turn-based that's gonna be on platform
they said at launch
i'm exclusive about that i want to see
how that go y'all know i'm a destiny fan
so you know where i'm gonna be with that
with game pass
so that was a cherry on top for me so
again selfishly again just speaking
about me i'm not saying
yo all the game is going to feel like
they go no relax that's not what i'm
saying
i'm feeling don't talk about cognito
where i'm at i just need
one hitter for me at no i know sony
gonna have bangers
but i'm just talking about one joint for
me
that gets me excited i yo that ninja
joining in for you
what do you think joint the jewish
captain the prophet is hot but that
that's not why i was running to god
it's not a joint that i'm going to spin
that's all i'm saying like it's cool you
know what i'm saying like but again i
just need something
you know how it is when you get no i'm
just trying to control it
i'm the type that when you get you open
the packaging you got that brand new
system
you want to showcase that joint you want
to see that's why racket
rushing clank wouldn't perfect because
like yo look at him going through the
different dimensions
you know what i'm saying like this is
what i'm like i want that joint you know
what i'm saying that's like this is ps5
we here you know what i'm saying and i
got even from the rogers and queen
i just like i like the technology that's
being used to see if the ssd work
yeah okay yeah listen there's nothing
that's going to be at launch i've
struggled with the same crap too
i said to myself but i i know me right
there's no way on this earth that a new
console is coming out and i'm not gonna
have it right
i don't care if they have nothing i
don't care if i just pick it up and i
just put it in the bushes and then and
because that's what happened in the
first one when i got it they had to do
that 24 hour download joint so
it kind of put itself in the bushes
anyway so
it sat there until games showed up right
you know and that's okay those are
people
with the bread to just be like okay do
what you're gonna do when you get there
yeah like i'm getting you
on hope do whatever you're gonna do we
know about you later right
that's what that is day one hype yeah
i'm more hype
day one for xbox series x for even my
whole back catalog to see what happens
when i play a game
like what's gonna go on but the
playstation
i okay this one game definitely
that's gonna i'm gonna buy miles morales
right of course period and and i have no
choice
but then then you start you gotta really
have a heart-to-heart question with a
lot of these uh consumers
are you paying 500 plus right for
miles morales right and and is it worth
it for you and
i see your struggle i i say the same
thing i didn't think about it until you
said it right til you said it i wasn't
really because i i thought you know how
we do
i'm thinking me you would solve walking
to the store then you talking about
i don't know i'm like
i'm like what do you mean you don't know
like it kind of threw me off yeah
really like i'm scared i just selfishly
just need something for me and i was
hoping
god for was that i thought god forbids
that i just wasn't thrown at a gameplay
luke i'm gonna be honest
i'm the same way uh godfather you guys
remember
when it was announced at the video game
awards i was there i was like let me see
and i kept seeing
i've cooled and gamepl just like all
right adequate fatigue is not
about what's going on
whatsoever all right godfall
is in the bushes and it godfall is
buried under the bush it's not even in
the bush i wasn't buying that game
at all uh you know and you know king oh
shout out to
demon gamer yes good question what about
demon souls y'all know i'm not i'm not
into that life i mean salute to y'all
with the
blood born and beating your head against
the wall and
the second row i feel y'all i'm old i
ain't got
to prove nothing to nobody i'm not doing
that like all that throwing controllers
at the screen
i'm not about that life those games
don't really interest me but i
understand mad people do like those
games though
i don't mind buying a console if there's
a game i want to play
yeah i bought zelda for i bought the
switch literally just for zelda for a
while
i literally bought another playstation
for final fantasy 7.
i don't want like ps5 when there's a
game that i want to play on the ps5
right
and i know people was like well hey what
about their their
their their track record well when they
have something that i want
then i will commit but i'm not buying
something to sit in my closet for six
months
like if demon says is there day one i'll
be there day one
right if the missiles are three months
after i'll be there three months after
but i'm not buying this for luke
whatever that game's called
like i'm not snack buck snack i'm not
buying this for bug snack
who's definitely not buying it for
spiderman okay
unless they give me something that i
want to play
i'm not buying it listen and i feel like
one of those people that's just like
you know king obviously can go by
because king likes that he likes that
new
item in his hand thing it's just like
i'm not that
i'm not that dude it's just like i will
buy it when a a title
is relevant that comes out i'm not about
this oh i'll buy it now because later on
if i would have waited later on when the
game came out that i wanted to i
probably could have got it cheaper
anyway
like i feel and that's again that's just
my thought i just want to get solved
and honest and then before where you at
with this man
i for me like i'm i'm in kind of the
same boat with king like i'm not gonna
have a new console out there and not get
it
even if there's nothing for it that i
that i i'm super excited about
obviously i'm excited for miles because
i know you know they're going to use a
hard drive or whatnot i you know i'm
kind of underwhelmed by the fact that
it's not going to be
a full-on you know 40-hour experience
but
whatever so that is enough for me on the
playstation side
on the xbox side i have to say and i've
been saying this for a while i'm i'm
in all likelihood i'm gonna splurge on
on a big time
gaming pc this gen that's i haven't done
it for a while so i'm gonna
probably do it okay so uh i i'm more
excited to see
the features of the series x that play
with my older games just out of the gate
just to see you know just to see
yeah go ahead i do think that's
something that people fail to mention
like you know we didn't have backwards
compatibility on the city on the
on the xbox at day one and i think with
the amount of
titles that's going to be backwards
compatible with the series x
and the lockhart there's going to be
more of a reason because if i do upgrade
uh my downtown's out of 10 the games
with my backlogs coming with me
right now obviously sony's been a little
vague on that we're
going but you know but they really told
us too much about that what they have
told us is miss max
mismatch miss messaging
jesus you know i just got to see more
information on that but right now
like on the xbox side besides that it's
in my older games like i'm gonna be
honest uh
when it comes to halo no no i'm the
hello guy you know i love halo
but i'm not you know i'm excited for the
120
fps i'm excited to see the reception to
being free to play i'm excited to see
here
the potential for halo to become bigger
than it ever has been
um the single player stuff i'm not happy
with the fact that ray tracing and that
next gen patch is not going to be there
day one
um so again they just said it would come
afterwards
yeah but what afterwards not day one we
don't know if it's day one it didn't say
not day one
i think they did though king i think
they did i think they did every time i
look for it and never said it
i need a fact check sir yeah
they said post launch the patch would
come post launching it could be 12
o'clock that night
how about he's out absolutely i
absolutely hope so um but that's pretty
much it like again if that because my
thing is that
what's the medium the medium does look
good too again i was a little
underwhelmed by this thing
by the 30 fps stuff underwhelming 30 fps
ray tracing sir
no they removed ray tracing from that
whole conversation no no
they
by that time i do have the gaming pc and
that 3080 then
more like that i'll be playing it at 60
with you know forward tracing
whatever so it's one of those things
where it's like at the launch
i'm gonna have it regardless because
that's just me yeah i'm not gonna not
have it yes
um but i'm i'm a little more
underwhelmed than i thought i would be
okay fair enough king launched lineups
my ex come with my stuff
it's not even a question you know i
literally have to buy anything i just
got to go pick up a console and go home
and play
everything so the playstation i'm gonna
spend
fifty dollars or seventy dollars on
miles morales that's i'm not buying
nothing else for them
i don't care what they do you know know
no god for
i just want to see your face i just want
to say god forbid i wasn't even
with god for when they were showing it
before i knew it was fo
gazi i know it was filler i knew it was
junk
i knew it right from the rip and anybody
sitting there talking about oh it's
going to be the new destiny you know
every every game that has attached
itself to a champion
which is destiny has fell under the
daggone rope
so hard hurt pay attention
the thing is is anthony didn't even get
in the wreath i told you about that here
i've got a solution if god fall looks
appealing to you
yes i'm going to save you 60 dollars
right now you're going to go on that
playstation 5.
you're going to hook it up to your tv
you're going to boot up that start menu
you're going to
just breathe in the glory of that start
menu and you're going to go to the store
and you're going to download warframe
for free
and it's going to do everything godfall
does except it already doesn't
work what you can do is get that serious
get that game and get that game pass
and have yesterday on deck okay yeah
but i'm not encouraging people to
download garbage okay
i feel like they might have just got got
blacklisted
i played that warframe and it was hot
trash damn
i tried i tried and and i know people
say yo
come back it's gotten better listen
anytime you've had a bad experience with
something like you go to a restaurant
and there's a rat
head in your soup oh are you going back
i'm not
going back to rat head soup you've
biscuit
that warframe is rat head soup oh i'm
not going back do it you can stop
talking about that
godfall look like they got flies and
they soup i'm not
buying that so i'm gonna stay where i
know the food is fine
i'm just gonna stay over here 60 frames
per second
get a super chance to get it we gotta
get out we got stitch with the five
dollar super chat godfall blue section
where underwater
with no bubbles
um then we have then we have clutch man
uh someone any with the fighter switch
someone anyone please make a next-gen
tmnt game with the recent life like
movie models
maybe i don't know i kind of like the
animated ones but the animated ones
yeah we have mariano with the five
dollars
what do lawyers think of lord rand's
video about the possibility of an even
cheaper lockhart but with no
controller i heard that roma yeah i've
been hearing that that sounds
crazy sounds great but crazy
text message right now wow okay
so in the industry i'ma tell you this
right
okay for all you playstation dudes
y'all left playstation already y'all
left them because
just nothing not the ones that got money
mm-hmm not
not the ones that got a uh not a tcl
not those guys y'all y'all guys are
gonna still come by
but to other dudes that was expecting
something else
mm-hmm what's up just cape crusher live
just right now okay
anyway in a minute look that are we
caught up
he said working in retail i have to have
both systems even with nothing from me
available day one on ps5 i can in good
conscience watch all these people tease
me
with their pressure
i feel that i feel that song we caught
up yeah we cut up all right cool man
let's
finish it up we're in reality man it's
not really finished if i told you you
know
right now as of me uh the best bang for
my buck until something actually comes
out for the playstation's the series x
you know destiny's
there day one luca none of them are
playing destiny like
uh that's one of the main reasons i'm
picking up the series x
a little bit less hype for halo infinite
after you know the reveal but i still
want to play it i'm still going to play
it right
uh but as of right now it's it's the
series x but it's like i said let that
demonstrate come out day one yeah
i'm with you like i just need one joint
for me that get me super pumped
and hopefully it's like an exclusive
joint that we ain't even hear about and
i'm good you know what i'm saying and
then i feel a little more confident i'm
probably still gonna bend anybody
i'm just just saying how i feel but
anyway let's get this pole up and get up
out of here
after the announcement of spider-man
being an exclusive character to the
playstation version of marvel avengers
which of the following answers most
resembles
your personal stance regarding exclusive
content
the choices are a no issue with
exclusive content tied to any platform
invest in your fan base b
only agree if exclusive content is timed
and not more than one year or c
make exclusive oh no actually it's four
choices excuse me make exclusive games
throw exclusive content in the bushes
or d i don't care if i don't get the
content i want it's automatically
anti-consumer
in the chat yo shout out to low toby
lord hogue and lord
undead for pulling up with a fantastic
show man oh man we
definitely hit the line today salute
salute toby with iron harvest again if
you caught that
please check him out man he was in the
realm with us did it up if you're into
rts
into that genre this is definitely one
to watch out for
tremendous stream with the lords and
undead and the crew
petey and attic please check that out
against the developers
and then of course log ho ho man the
business love firm himself
bringing his spicy takes of course so
it's always good to have him in the
realm and salute him follow hoglar on
youtube
and of course let's get undead lords of
gaming dot nets
oh edit that and host of the gaming
perspective where can i find people find
you what you got going on sir
uh people can find me on twitter send me
all your hate mail you can find me on
undead three xvi your hate fulfills me i
check my message
um and the uptick in
uh slurs towards me has been fantastic
i need to recertify i am irish canadian
so using um
mexican racial slurs against me is an
interesting job
i appreciate it i appreciate it i
appreciate the attempts
but you can also find my podcast on the
gaming perspective youtube channel
there's some stuff
i'm gonna start deconstructing news and
editorial style videos coming up
on that so you'll see things like you
know why spiderman being exclusive can
be good or bad
and things like that so you can hop on
over and subscribe to that if you're
so interested the podcast goes live 8
p.m eastern standard time
every saturday usually sometime sunday
depending on scheduling but
yeah and you can find all of my written
work at lordsofgaming.net
and everything we cover and the
fantastic work
that is done by the entire team of the
website
absolutely man solution to the website
it's a lost game that naturally dizzy
he was in there man he has some great
great points and great articles as well
in reference to um the samsung deals
though
cloud gaming salute to the whole team
man we've got some tremendous talent man
if you're interested
in very games very platforms you know
what i'm saying and
these guys are killing it i'm super
proud and humbled that they write for us
we have tremendous talent undead it's
definitely
one of the driving forces behind that so
salute you brother keep it up
always a pleasure to have you in the
realm and again gaming perspective y'all
check it out man check it out really
good podcast these guys listen man
they're talking real educated talk none
of the nonsense
please support them great group of guys
eric jackson and of course lords of
gaming.net's own
ray's virus is on there as well jared
he's awesome and of course
the amazing sam tober of windows central
man check that out these guys are real
gamers
real information and you get some fact
checking done
with all the fraudery so go in there and
check them out man it's really good
solid podcast so that's what i got lord
addict with the c
or the t or the which one i don't know
that took the l dot
where hey the five people find you what
do you have going on sir
it's it's lord addict well for c if
something bad happens since it's a t
when everything's good all right no
doubt so uh you can find me on twitter
at lord addicts iop you can find me on
youtube at gaming addict
um got some videos probably coming out
tomorrow
and you can find me next week right back
here eating on the podcast
because once it's over three o'clock man
i'm on borrow time all right fair
enough sir always a pleasure please
check out his videos my boy is out here
killing it with the videos thumbnail
game on fleek
great opinions going on he's been
rocking it and he's been doing also some
iop first look streams
i think he did dead age two for us for
launch gaming.net that was awesome
and yeah man please support him and he's
out here moving and shaking and taking
the challenges
so that's what we got solved we're gonna
get the super chat before we get your
outro certainly
got atl with the five dollar super chat
do you think another reason sony took
away console exclusives is to keep away
comparisons of third-party games which
will look better on the x
well they didn't take away the game the
game was gonna to be then
the comparison is going to be made
anyway
no no no doubt so lord sovereign getting
the sony base behind them they would
like
talk their hustlers talk spin that
exclusive
birthday funny you know the funny thing
is that i get labeled the sony people
saudi nation is here for some they say
the only appeal
lord spit facts forget them other lords
that's the lord well
doubt uh big shout out to toby and hogan
and deb for coming through uh
always funny man hogan hogan's hilarious
dude and toby
toby is on another level um uh
definitely check
check check out iop's interview with him
uh it was
e3 or pax a couple of years back oh he's
just a character you doing too much cat
daddy
lord and savior sovereign christ you do
it too much
listen i know my man is nice but y'all
not gonna make this and he's the best
lord i feel the way that
i feel they give and solve the title is
the best lord y'all what's going
on i'm over here i'm the pragmatic lord
definitely big shout out to those guys
and yeah i'm going to work so that's
what i'm going to be doing um
try to continue my uh ghost of sushima
play
like i said last week i'm really playing
it straight sam right now like
it's just not it it isn't really a
stealth game like it's
it's serviceable and i wish it were more
it was just the a.i
is a little bit wait it's like 25
stealth 75 my swords going in your
throat
yeah i didn't even think about it i even
think about that those are
bad boys bad boys sponsorships lost
salute
of course lord king tired of all the
nonsense it's as dudes we run around wow
the fake insiders and the
upsetting tcl nation once again
where can the fine people find you what
you got going on sir first of all i want
to say shout out to tobe behold
and my man i'm dead yes keep out here
putting out that
work on dude bro
yeah it's crazy um yeah but
i really want to salute you because like
i said i knew you was like michael
jordan so
yeah it's really i just really want to
salute you and let you know that if i
don't tell you to your face i'll tell
you
your face right now and then he was very
happy with the signing
oh yes
like we all were we oh a lot of people
were popping bottles bro when you came
and kind knows an undead nose as soon as
he got signed i was like my savior
well i know why yeah i know why you
because it took you over right
okay yeah new kos is up he's getting
come up um
the box is right there i just didn't
want to overwork uh cognito
and i had uh i did my whole back room
like i've been
like doing some little documentaries
with it
in these new shelves that i'm working
with back there and they you know they
hold
on at least 90 percent of my stature
collection i move most of them back
there so i have a whole free space
in my main room that i'm going to
populate and i have new shelving that's
coming over here that
it's just going to look bananas so stuff
will change around you i can watch it
organically change and also
go to uh dolph castlex on friday nights
just just just tune in listen to the
talk it's kind of funny you would have
saw
uh barbara running to the store on a red
bull run
live with a camera and she put on her ma
it was the wildest thing because we did
not know what was going on
when her camera switched and she's in
the street we was like
crazy he's coming it's good
so it's definitely something to watch
please
watch the last word look i get already
how you feel about um them taking away
our break from
yeah yeah yeah we're not gonna talk
about that because that got me upset and
i'm trying to move forward
i try to move forward i try to watch you
guys right but at this point i'm so
removed from destiny
when i tell you it is another language
that's what people say you
you guys will talk for like minutes and
it's not even
english to me yeah that's why it goes he
said to say that he's like yo i don't
know what it is
what's going on but it is the most
passionate thing i just love the passage
i like when they fight that's all i
tuned in for
because i'm guaranteed uh let's get
ready to rumble moment
and cog we stand on his square but he
wants to be bobbing away with them
breaking them down sometimes
so uh yeah please tune in to that uh
follow me on
uh instagram well follow us on
every social media that's
lordsofgaming.net on the
on the net uh that's iron lords podcast
on youtube that's iron lord podcast on
twitter that's iron loyal podcast on
instagram and that's iron lord podcast
on tick tock yes
the kids is on tick tock we out there
you know popping a lot we got attic
and a plumber suit dancing so you got to
go check that out if you look for that
and it's not down for you you aren't
going to post that
that was that was adequate for c though
it's coming we got to make that second
order man but look but you know yeah
please follow us uh thank you for all
the support
everybody was rocking in here man this
is truly humbling
and all you do is that tuned in for that
state of play
i didn't even think it was going to be
it was some impromptu stuff that we
decided to do
and you rock with us i really truly
appreciate it shout out to dilapo for
making
uh that was just that of
you with text on it was
i didn't even realize the things you
were saying i'm like yo we kind of funny
so
because i was laughing too oh my god
salute to y'all we just want to give
some love back to the realm man of
course you don't already know the
lords were in the room everybody look
enjoy your sunday next week oh solve we
will we we got to go to a patreon joint
for next week yeah yeah we got to get
that and we'll do some winners do some
giveaways and we have some cool things
lined up yo
that's all i got we're gonna give y'all
an outro with king everybody enjoy your
sunday we out of here until next week
hi i'm lord king david of iron lords
podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway this giveaway is like none
other
we'll be giving away a xbox series x
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able to be
part of that giveaway there's two ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
hit that joy button you hit that join
button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
that's the who did that for you
sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy